zuverlässig viel in der Deutschen
Bundestag schauen werden aber wo wir
auch einige Stopps machen die durchaus
auch in politischen Berlin stattfinden
aber von Wichtigkeit sind zum Beispiel
wollen wir gegen 14 Uhr der deutschen
Wirtschaft den Puls fühlen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
wird dies tun und wird die
Herbstprojektion vorstellen dass bei uns
live im Laufe des Nachmittags geht es
auch um bezahlbaren Wohnraum mit der
bauministerin Clara gaiwetz und dem
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz auch das
zeigen wir Ihnen im Laufe dieser
nächsten Stunden wir beginnen aber im
Deutschen Bundestag den werden Sie
gleich hier hinter mir schon live sehen
es ist eine ganz klassische Plenarwoche
und die beginnt sehr gern mit einer
Befragung eines Mitglieds der
Bundesregierung man könnte sagen zum
Start des corona-herbstes einige
Bemerkungen aus profundem bunte
profundemunde zu Gast sein wird der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und meine Kollegin Jeanette
Clark begleitet für uns die Sitzung wir
geben ab nach Berlin abgewichen werden
in diesen Minuten hat die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bars die
Sitzung eröffnet wir hören mal kurz rein
FTP einer aktuelle Stunde mit dem Titel
Ergebnisse der unabhängigen Kommission
Erdgas und Wärme der Bundesregierung
sicher durch den Winter
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 wird abgesetzt und
an dieser Stelle Tagesordnungspunkt 23
mit einer debattendauer von 39 Minuten
aufgerufen am Donnerstag soll
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 abgesetzt werden
ebenso ist vorgesehen Tagesordnungspunkt
10 abzusetzen und an dieser Stelle Tages
hat zum Auftakt dieser Sitzungswoche
diese Sitzungstages wie immer
vorzunehmen was es noch ein Änderung in
der Tagesordnung gab und sie haben schon
als wir uns gerade draufgeschaltet haben
gehört was diesen Nachmittag nämlich
betrifft im weiteren Verlauf hier dieses
Sitzungstages gibt es nämlich eine
Aktuelle Stunde beantragt von den
Fraktionen der Ampelkoalition zu den
Vorschlag pflegen der Gaspreis
Kommission also das wird sicher
interessant dass dann ungefähr gegen 15
Uhr 15 aber auf der Regierungsbank da
hat schon Platz genommen und das soll ja
der erste Tagesordnungspunkt sein wie
schon angedeutet die Befragung der
Bundesregierung mit
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach der sich hier eine Stunde
lang sie sehen ihn hier von der Regie
schön eingefangen der sich eine Stunde
lang eine gute Stunde lang hier den
Abgeordneten
den Fragen der Abgeordneten stellen wird
er darf zu Beginn einen fünfminütigen
einleitungsvortrag halten
zu einem Thema aus seinem Ressort und
sie haben wir hören mal den
Bundesminister Karl Lauterbach
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst mal
lassen Sie mich beginnen mit der
corona-situation wir sind am Beginn
einer herbst- und winterwelle die es
kommt nicht überraschend wir sind aber
auf diese Welle sehr gut vorbereitet wir
haben zunächst einmal im Rahmen der
Beschaffung von angepassten Impfstoffen
Impfstoffe beschaffen die auf die
Varianten mit denen wir derzeit zu
ringen haben gut vorbereitet sind so
dass sie versicherten eine Auswahl haben
zwischen entsprechend angepassten
Impfstoffen wir haben darüber hinaus die
den Panamera da eingeführt der
pandemerada erlaubt es den Ländern
präzise zu erkennen wie die jeweilige
Situation in ihren Ländern ist so dass
sie relativ früh reagieren können wir
haben für die besonders hohen Gruppen
Arzneimittel beschäftigt die
Sterblichkeit der Patienten deutlich
senken können diese Arzneimittel sind in
den Pflegeeinrichtungen
gelagert worden werden dort gelagert und
können durch Hausärzte direkt abgegeben
werden so dass wir dort eine deutlich
verbesserte versorgen der Patienten
erwarten können und schließlich haben
wir mit dem Infektionsschutzgesetz was
wir übrigens Sommer vorbereitet haben
die Länder in die Lage versetzt auf der
Grundlage der vorhandenen Daten
entsprechend infektionsschutzmaßnahmen
vorzunehmen insbesondere die
maskenpflicht in den Innenräumen
einzuführen aber auch wenn das notwendig
wäre diese auszudehnen wenn es ganz
schlimm käme sogar in Außenbereichen
aber davon gehen wir derzeit nicht aus
ich appelliere an die Länder die also
Verantwortung auch wahrzunehmen wir
sehen derzeit stark steigende Fallzahlen
ich höre aber das die Länder diese
Maßnahmen auch derzeit kontrollieren bzw
diskutieren ich gehe daher mit einem
Freund ich gehe daher von einem
verantwortungsvollen Handeln gehe ich
aus zum zweiten die Krankenhäuser sind
an der Situation wo Sie also mit
steigenden Energiekosten insbesondere
Stromkosten aber auch Gas konfrontiert
sind darüber hinaus ist die Inflation
stärker als das was die
landesbasiswahlwerte an zusätzlichen
Einnahmen erwarten lassen darauf werden
wir reagieren indem wir im Rahmen
unseres 200 Milliarden schutzpaketes die
Länder in die Lage versetzen werden die
Krankenhäuser zu unterstützen die
Krankenhäuser auch direkt unterstützen
und schließlich möchte ich darauf
hinweisen wir haben ein Finanz eine
Finanzlücke von 17 Milliarden in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung das
werden wir in den nächsten Wochen durch
das finanzstabilisierungsgesetz werden
das Ausgleichen wir sind am Vorabend
wichtiger Gesetze und ich will hier nur
numerisch ganz kurz zusammenfassen dass
wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
insgesamt also zwölf Gesetze ich ans
Netz bringen werden die wir dann mit
Ihnen diskutieren werden wir werden für
die Kinderheilkunde die wahlpauschalen
überwinden bei der Versorgung von
Kindern erwäsischer Schritt nach vorn
wir werden der Geburtshilfe zur Lösungen
kommen dass die Geburtshilfe auf dem
Land sichergestellt werden kann wir
werden Tages-
nicht übernachten müssen wo dieses
medizinisch nicht notwendig ist wir
werden das diad-system weiterentwickeln
so dass auch vorhaltepauschalen
berücksichtigt werden können so dass die
Krankenhäuser besser dort platziert sind
wo auch der Bedarf ist im Rahmen der
Digitalisierung haben wir zwei
Schwerpunkte die elektronische
Patientenakte wird als ob artakter
eingeführt wir werden darüber hinaus
auch das e-rezept also etwas anders
organisieren nach vorne bringen
gesundheitskioske als Siebte Maßnahme
werden in den besonders benachteiligten
Städten und Stadtteilen die Versorgung
ergänzen wir werden durch das
Krankenpflege entlastungsgesetz die
Pflegekräfte deutlich entlasten und wir
werden darüber hinaus also auch für die
Langzeitpflege eine Finanzierungsreform
vorschlagen die die also Langzeitpflege
sicherstellt die unabhängige
Patientenberatung wird das durch das
upd-gesetz also verbessert wir werden
eine Gesetzgebung zur Legalisierung von
Cannabis also vorstellen wo insbesondere
der Gesundheitsschutz im Vordergrund
steht so dass Cannabis tatsächlich so
konsumiert werden kann dass diejenigen
die es konsumieren gesichert sind und
dass der Gesundheitsschutz beim
Cannabiskonsum im Vordergrund steht es
geht hier nicht um die Ausweitung des
Konsums und schließlich werden wir
Gesetze vorstellen wo wir die
psychotherapeutische Versorgung
verbessern und zwar sowohl in den
Krankenhäusern wie auch im ambulanten
Bereich also 12 gesetzliche Grundlagen
die wir derzeit vorbereiten ich freue
mich auf die Diskussion dieser wichtigen
Gesetze mit Ihnen
vielen Dank wir beginnen die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen des Bundesministers Herrn
Dr Karl Lauterbach und zum
Geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung und mit
allgemeinen Fragen
schon mal prophylaktisch vorab der erste
Fragesteller oder die erste
Fragestellerin hat jeweils eine Minute
sowohl für die Frage und der Minister
hat dann jeweils eine Minute für die
Antwort also immer auf die Zeit achten
und für die Nachfrage allerdings nur 30
Sekunden jeweils will das nur schon mal
vorab sagen damit alle noch mal
wissen wie das Verfahren hier gleich ist
das Wort hat zuerst als erster
Fragesteller der Kollege Tino Sorge aus
der cdu/cd CSU-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesgesundheitsminister
zahlreiche Kliniken Pflegeheime und
Arztpraxen sind durch die Inflation von
fast 10 Prozent und massiv gestiegene
Energiepreise in ihrer Existenz
gefährdet sie haben es gerade eben noch
mal angesprochen die Bundesregierung
weiß seit Monaten von dieser Thematik
unternimmt aber leider nichts dagegen
Insolvenzen und Schließungen drohen
bereits deshalb würde mich konkret
interessieren wann genau kommt endlich
das Rettungspaket für die
Infrastrukturen Gesundheitswesen aus dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
die vielen Dank für die Frage die
Grundlage für die Abschätzung wie groß
der Bedarf in den Krankenhäusern ist ist
er jetzt am Wochenende geschaffen worden
weil wir durch das allgemeine
Rettungspaket jetzt einen Fahrplan haben
wie wir die Energiekosten in Deutschland
Bremsen werden davon werden auch die
Krankenhäuser profitieren da werden aber
dann wahrscheinlich noch restbelastungen
und verbleiben wie diese Restbelastung
und ausgeglichen werden wird derzeit von
meinem Haus vorbereitet ich bin
diesbezüglich auch in direkten
Verhandlungen mit Finanzminister Lindner
und wir werden somit Ihnen unmittelbar
vortragen aber wir haben hier drei
Blöcke wir haben im Prinzip die
steigenden Gaskosten die Stromkosten und
den inflationsbereich der durch also die
steigende landesbasisfall wird
Veränderung nicht abgedeckt ist und wir
werden alle drei Bereiche werden wir
entsprechend abfedern
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
vielen Dank Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das sind ja im
Grunde das was sie seit Monaten tun im
Grunde nur Ankündigungen deshalb würde
mich interessieren wir haben bereits im
April darauf hingewiesen ich habe ihn
bereits im April dazu auch ein Schreiben
auch im mit Blick auf die wirklich
kritische Situation in den Kliniken
geschickt wir haben als Union vor der
Sommerpause diesbezüglich schon einen
Antrag eingebracht und deshalb würde
mich jetzt interessieren von ihnen warum
ihr Haus bisher untätig geblieben ist
und keine konkreten Maßnahmen vorgelegt
hat ich habe ja gerade also ausgeführt
dass die Voraussetzung für die
Berechnung der Bedarfe in den
Krankenhäusern erst am Wochenende
geschaffen wurde indem wir uns eben auf
das also Schutzpaket beziehen und dort
lässt sich dann abschätzen wie hoch die
Mehrbedarfe für die sozialen
Einrichtungen sind das ist ja auch in
den Papier der Expertenkommission genau
beschrieben somit wir haben das Papier
jetzt am Wochenende bekommen und ich
bitte daher um Nachsicht dass ich nicht
schon vor Monaten dieses Ergebnis
vorwegnehmen konnte
gibt es zu diesem Thema weitere
Nachfragen Kollege pilsinger
der Bundesminister die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft hat in dieser
Woche ja auch deutlich gemacht dass die
Vorschläge der gaspreiskommission hinten
und vorne nicht ausreichen um die
Krankenhäuser zu entlasten zwei Drittel
der ungedeckten Kosten sei nicht
aufgrund der Energiekosten sondern doch
Kostensteigerung bei den
Medizinprodukten Arzneimitteln
Lebensmitteln und Dienstleistungen
entstanden wie werden sie denn
sicherstellen dass unsere Krankenhäuser
nicht unter dieser Kosten Last
zusammenbrechen und deswegen noch mal
die Frage bis wann wollen Sie den
Gesetzesvorschlag einbringen da es kein
zeitlichen Verzug mehr geben darf bei
der Stabilisierung unserer Krankenhäuser
ich hatte ja eben selbst eingeräumt dass
die Vorschläge der Kommission nicht
ausreichen um das Delta komplett zu
beseitigen ich hob darauf ab dass die
inflationskosten die Differenz zwischen
der Entwicklung der landesbasisfall
Werte und das also in medizinischen
inflations also gesch in den
Krankenhäusern abgedeckt werden muss ich
hatte darauf hingewiesen dass ich in
Gesprächen mit Finanzminister Lindner
diesbezüglich sind wenn der Mehrbedarf
ist bekannt und der Mehrbedarf wird auch
mit der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft und mit
einzelnen Kliniken im Detail besprochen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen wenn
Sie möchten muss aber nicht
noch nicht beantwortet bis wann sie das
Gesetz vorlegen wollen das war meine
Frage und deswegen die bitte ob Sie eine
zeitliche Einschätzung bringen können
bis wann sie es machen wollen
ja das kann ich wir werden das
rechtzeitig machen
gibt es zum Thema Krankenhaus und
Energiekosten steigen noch eine Frage
Herr Minister wenn ich bald etwas
passiert wird es zu einer kalten
Strukturreform kommen
Rehakliniken Pflegeeinrichtungen und
Praxen werden schließen
Versorgungsengpässe für breite
Bevölkerungsschichten drohen mich würde
interessieren wie genau soll ein
Rettungsschirm aussehen und noch mal
gefragt diese Aussage reicht mir
eigentlich nicht ganz was die zeitliche
Situation und Schiene betrifft wann soll
er kommen
ich weiß bereits darauf hin dass die
Gespräche mit
Finanzminister Lindner bereits begonnen
haben und in der nächsten Woche
fortgesetzt werden dass wir auf das
Ergebnis der Expertenkommission am
Sonntag warten mussten eine Abschätzung
des Mehrbedarfs vorher nicht möglich war
auch die Ergebnisse der
Expertenkommission müssen jetzt erst
einmal in gesetzgeberische Maßnahmen
übersetzt werden so dass wir parallel in
der Vorbereitung dieser
gesetzgeberlichen Maßnahmen für den
Energiebedarf insgesamt bereits im
Krankenhaussektor mit abdecken wir haben
das voll im Blick und wir werden das
rechtzeitig machen es war keine
polemische Bemerkung sondern ich bin mit
den Krankenhäusern im engen Austausch
auch mit dem Präsidenten oder mit dem
Geschäftsführer der
Krankenhausgesellschaft und daher können
sich darauf verlassen ich habe ja sehr
früh auf dieses Thema hingewiesen wir
haben das im Blick und werden es lösen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank Herr Minister eine Nachfrage
teilen Sie die Einschätzung der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft dass
sich die
Finanzierungslücke bei Sachkosten und
Energie auf rund 15 Milliarden Euro in
diesem und im kommenden Jahr summiert
können Sie das Abschätzen bitte diese
Einschätzung kann ich nicht teilen weil
das würde ja bedeuten dass ich in der
Lage wäre die Entwicklung der Preise für
zum Beispiel Gas und Strom im nächsten
Jahr vorherzusehen dazu bin ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht in der
Lage und ich bin auch nicht ganz sicher
ob die Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
dazu in der Lage ist
so ich sehe dazu keine weiteren
Nachfragen
[Musik]
Frau Zöllner sie dürfen
nicht stell liebe Kollegen die Frage
nicht noch mal anders lieber Herr
Minister mir geht's auch noch ein paar
darum um das Thema Energie und das ist
zum Beispiel für die ambulanten
Pflegedienste natürlich ganz konkret im
ländlichen Raum des Thema der
Spritpreise was planen sie da in dem
Bereich auch darauf haben wir schon vor
Monaten hingewiesen und deswegen die
Frage was wird konkret für die
ambulanten
Pflegedienste da vorgesehen im Bereich
des Sprits was ja sozusagen deren
wichtigstes Instrument ist um von A nach
B mit beispielsweise dem Auto zu kommen
ja in der Tat vielen Dank für diese
Frage Frau Abgeordnete sowohl für die
stationären Pflegeeinrichtungen wie auch
für die ambulanten Pflegedienste ergeben
sich Mehrkosten die durch die jetzigen
Verträge die ja oft auch langfristigerer
Natur sind nicht abgedeckt sind daher
planen wir dort die Möglichkeit die
Verträge kurzfristige anzupassen so dass
die zusätzlichen Kosten es sind ja nicht
nur
Benzinkosten sondern sind auch andere
Kosten dazu gekommen sind dass diese
umgelegt werden können also es muss auf
jeden Fall gewährleistet sein durch eine
Verkürzung der jeweiligen
Vertragsabschlüsse dass die also
Mehrkosten weitergegeben werden können
an die Pflegekassen und die
Refinanzierung bei den Pflegekassen
refinanziert dann das data
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank und auch hier die Frage weil
das natürlich zeitlich einfach alle
unter Druck stehen wann rechnen Sie
damit zeitlich ganz konkret für ein
Signal für die ambulanten Pflegedienste
gerade in den ländlichen Räumen
für die also stationäre Versorgung haben
wir ja die verkürzte Vertrags also
Geltung bereits beschlossen im Kabinett
mit der also wohngeldreform die die
Pflege mit abdeckt Wohngeld Plus oder
das dort kurzfristig diese Zusatzkosten
weitergegeben werden können eine
ähnliche Regelung für die ambulanten
Dienste ist in Vorbereitung
bevor ich die nächsten Nachfrage Aufrufe
ich will noch mal erinnern zum gleichen
Thema wir waren ursprünglich beim
Krankenhaus und den Energiekosten jetzt
sind wir schon ausgeweitet auf die
ambulanten Dienste aber jetzt bitte bei
diesem Thema bleiben damit wir die
anderen Fragen auch noch berücksichtigen
können das als nächstes hat das Wort ich
glaube der Kollege Reichert aus der
afd-fraktion
bis da ich habe ebenfalls eine Frage im
Bereich der ambulanten Pflegedienste
es haben etliche Bürger mir mitgeteilt
dass sie Informationen ihrer
entsprechenden Pflegedienstleister
erhalten haben dass aufgrund der
steigenden Energiekosten
gegebenenfalls zum Beispiel statt bisher
vier Stunden Pflegeleistung pro Woche
nur noch drei Stunden und ähnliches
erbracht werden können meine Frage dazu
haben Sie
Informationen darüber in welchem Umfang
das geschieht wie sehen sie diese
Situation und was planen Sie um hier den
Bürgern Sicherheit zu geben
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage zunächst einmal also eine
Verkürzung der Pflege Leistungen
einseitig durch den Pflegedienst ist
natürlich nicht erlaubt und ist mir auch
nicht bekannt das wäre ja auch ein Bruch
mit den geldenden Regeln und dann würde
sich die Frage stellen ob der
Pflegedienst dann die Leistung noch so
erbracht hat dass sie überhaupt
abgerechnet werden können grundsätzlich
haben Sie aber recht dass wir mit
Mehrbelastungen in der ambulanten Pflege
zu rechnen haben und daher habe ich eben
schon bei der Frage von der Abgeordneten
Zahlen darauf hingewiesen dass wir die
Verkürzung der Vertragslaufzeiten
zwischen Pflegekassen und Pflegediensten
planen so dass die Mehrkosten
weitergegeben werden können an die
Pflegekassen und dass wir diese dann
refinanzieren im Rahmen der Maßnahmen
die ich eben angesprochen habe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ich
gehe also davon aus dass sie ich nehme
aus ihren Aussagen dass Sie
sicherstellen dass es durch die erhöhten
Kosten im Bereich der Pflege nicht zu
einem Rückgang der Pflegequalität der
Menschen vor Ort kommt genau davon gehe
ich raus ich gehe davon aus dass die
Pflegequalität nicht senken wird obwohl
wir in dieser Krisensituation sind weil
wir die Leistungen so finanzieren werden
dass sie in der Qualität erbracht werden
können wie sie bisher erbracht worden
von daher gehe ich nicht davon aus dass
wir einen Einbruch oder ein Absinken der
Pflegequalität weder im ambulanten noch
im stationären Sektor haben
Nachfrage aus der SPD-Fraktion die
Kollegen baradari zum gleichen Thema
frau Präsidentin genau zu dem Thema Herr
Minister vielen herzlichen Dank für ihre
Ausführung für die Investitionskosten
der Krankenhäuser sind die Länder
zuständig und in vielen Ländern sind da
keine Investition getätigt worden auch
in Hinblick darauf was Gebäudesanierung
oder erneuerbare Energien angeht könnten
sie uns vielleicht darstellen wo noch
Verbesserungsbedarf Bundesseite ich aber
vor allen Dingen in der Zuständigkeit
der Länder vielleicht auch in Bezug auf
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bordeaux und dort
noch Verbesserungsbedarf ist ja vielen
Dank Frau Abgeordnete für diese Frage in
der Tat ist es so dass die Länder seit
vielen Jahren ihren Investitionskosten
nicht nachkommen das hat zur Folge dass
zum Teil die Heizkosten deutlich höher
sind als sie sonst sein müssten weil die
Heizanlagen zum Teil veraltet und
ineffizient sind von der Dämmung der
also Gebäude ganz abzusehen somit sind
die Gebäude im Sommer zu heiß und im
Winter zu kalt und müssen entsprechen
geheizt werden wir werden jetzt noch
viele Gelegenheiten haben mit den
Ländern über dieses Defizit zu
verhandeln zunächst im Rahmen der
Umsetzung des also entlastungspaketes
welches ich eben angesprochen habe für
welches wir die Kommissionsvorschläge am
Wochenende bekommen haben da wird es
viele Verhandlungen mit den Ländern
geben was sind die Verpflichtungen der
Länder wir werden aber auch im Rahmen
der von mir eben angesprochenen
krankenhausgesetze diese Gelegenheit
haben ich hatte ja darauf hingewiesen
dass wir das fahrpauschalsystem
überwinden wollen bei der
Kinderheilkunde wir wollen die
Geburtshilfe also besser abdecken wir
wollen die fahrpauschalen so verändern
dass also der stationäre Aufenthalt da
wo nicht nötig nicht erbracht werden
muss und dass derg-system das
fahrpauschalensystem insgesamt
verbessern somit wir werden über viele
Monate jetzt mit den Ländern verhandeln
und bei diesen Gelegenheiten immer
wieder auch über die investitionszusage
und Verpflichtungen der länderverhandeln
können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Dank ich wüsste ganz gerne ob es da
spezielle Gespräche gibt auch mit dem
Gesundheitsminister Herr Laumann in NRW
als das bevölkerungsreichste Bundesland
interessiert ist mich natürlich auch als
Abgeordnete aus dem Land sehr
an der Tat ist also auch dass Bundesland
nach der Nordrhein-Westfalen den
Verpflichtungen nicht nachgekommen
sind aus früheren Gesprächen ist mir das
bekannt diese Defizite bekannt und
bisher habe ich aber von ihm nicht
gehört wie er diesen Verpflichtungen
begegnen möchte
vielen Dank ich habe noch eine Nachfrage
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE zum gleichen
Thema Kollege
Göppinger vielen vielen Dank ist besitzt
auf die Antwort auf die auf die Ebene
gestellte Frage von den Lauterbach sie
haben eben gerade gesagt in der
Einführung auch schon dass sie von ihrem
bisherigen Plan im Koalitionsvertrag
absehen dass sie nur die
Kinderheilkunde dort dort nur die
Fallpauschalen rausnehmen wollen sie
haben das im Koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten auch für die
Notfallversorgung für die
Kinderheilkunde und für die Geburtshilfe
und zwar kurzfristig jetzt möchte ich
noch mal nachfragen inwiefern ihre eben
gestellte also ihren gegebene Antwort
tatsächlich der Realität entspricht
damit aber dem Koalitionsvertrag
widerspricht dass sie kurzfristig in
allen dreien Bereichen uns doch zu wenig
aber immerhin dort die Fallpauschalen
von Fallpauschalen absehen wollen
herzlichen Dank ja vielen Dank Herr
Abgeordnete ich bitte mal entschuldigung
dass ich nicht genau erkennen konnte ob
sie verspätet eingetroffen sind aber ich
weiß ja darauf hin dass wir in der
Kinderheilkunde die fahrpauschalen
überwinden wollen dass wir bei der
Geburtshilfe durch ein anderes System
die Geburtshilfe auf dem Bereich
darstellen wollen dass wir die
Fallpauschalen verändern wollen in der
stationären Versorgung dass der
ambulante die ambulante Erbringung
möglich ist und dass wir das
Gesamtsystem der fahrpauschalen
dahingehend weiterentwickeln wollen oder
auch überwinden wollen dass es
vorhaltepauschalen gibt und auch andere
Elemente die da Sicherstellung der
Krankenhäuser genügen es ist also
insgesamt ein großes Programm zur
Verbesserung der Qualität in der
Krankenhausversorgung und zur
entökonomisierung es ist die größte
Reform an diesem System Seite Einführung
der fahrpauschalen und wird im
Wesentlichen das jetzt bestehende System
der fahrpauschalen überwinden
ich habe jetzt wieder mehrere Nachfragen
ich hoffe jetzt nicht dass es als neue
Thema Fallpauschalen ist wir waren immer
noch bei Energieversorgung aber sie
dürfen jetzt noch eine Nachfrage stellen
also mir unangenehm weil es in gewisser
Weise schon noch mal auf die Antwort von
der Lauterbach zurück führt ich war
nämlich nicht nur heute schon um 13 Uhr
da gewesen sonst hätte ich auch schon
bei der vereinbarungskoalitionsvertrages
zumindest habe ich ihn lesen können wenn
ich das schon nicht dabei war beim
Verhandlungen und dort habe ich
zumindest gesehen dass alle drei
Bereiche aus den Fallpauschalen
rausfallen soll und zwar kurzfristig
deswegen haben die die Frage wollen sie
die Notfallversorgung wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart aus den
Fallpauschalen rausnehmen wie
versprochen oder nicht
ja vielen Dank Abgeordnete die
Notfallversorgung ist auch jetzt nicht
durch die fahrpauschalen abgedeckt das
ist eine Bezahlung die anders
organisiert ist und ich habe ja darauf
hingewiesen in meiner letzten Antwort
dass wir eine komplette Reform machen
für das gesamte fahrpauschalsystem was
die fahrpauschalen dahingehend
überwindet das dann eben mit
vorhaltepauschalen gearbeitet wird
sicherstellungszuschlägung mit einigen
anderen Elementen kann ich jetzt hier
nicht also diskutieren in der kurz in
der Kürze der Zeit aber somit wurde das
bestehende Fallpauschalensystem dann für
alle Bereiche würde das überwunden das
würde die von Ihnen angesprochenen
beispielbereiche enthalten
so die nächste Frage zum Thema stellt
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
die Kollegin Weishaupt
das ist keine Sabotage hier kann sich
jeder Abgeordnete melden so und die Frau
Weisshaupt hat jetzt die Gelegenheit
Ihre Frage zu stellen vielen Dank liebe
Präsidentin lieber Herr Minister sie
haben ja gerade schon die Geburtshilfe
angesprochen jetzt würde ich da noch mal
gerne nachfragen was das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium dann auch
plant um die Gesundheitsversorgung rund
um die Geburt tatsächlich auch konkret
zu verbessern
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat in der Geburtshilfe
haben wir die Situation dass die
Kliniken die derzeit den sogenannten
sicherstellungszuschlag bekommen mit
diesem sicherstellungszuschlag alleine
die Geburtshilfe nicht so darstellen
können dass Qualität und
Versorgungsangebot gesichert sind daher
arbeiten wir an Modellen wo also hier
Zuschläge gewährleistet werden die
auskömmlich sind sodass die Geburtshilfe
dort auch wirklich dargestellt werden
kann und dabei soll auch unterschieden
werden ob das Kliniken sind wo eine
Pädiatrie gleich eine
kinderheilkundestation gleichzeitig
vorgehalten wird oder nicht so dass wir
an qualitätsanrats geben aber das
zentrale Ziel ist dass die Kliniken die
sich alleine die Geburtshilfe nicht
erwirtschaften können aus diesem
wirtschaftlichen Druck komplett
herausgenommen werden und so unterstützt
werden dass die Sicherstellung
unabhängig von der Zahl der Geburten
gewährleistet ist dafür wäre dann der
alte sicherstellungszustellenschlag
zuständig dann eine zusätzliche
Finanzierung und so eine dritte
finanzierungssäule die davon abhängen
würde ob es auch eine Geburtshilfe gibt
oder nein das ist derzeitige Stand der
Diskussion wir werden sie in kürzer
damit einem Referent mit einem
entwurfgesetzentwurf konfrontieren
sie dürfen noch eine Nachfrage stellen
und wirklich jetzt keine neuen Themen
beginnen Frau Präsident
in sie haben auf die Nachfrage
verzichtet jetzt lasse ich noch eine zu
nämlich von der FDP dann haben wir alle
in dieser Runde einmal gehabt und dann
würde ich wirklich gerne so langsam zur
nächsten angemeldeten Frage rübergehen
Frau Aschenberg dougnos sie dürfen jetzt
noch nachfragen ursprünglich war es mal
Krankenhaus und Energiekosten bitte frau
Präsidentin ist hat natürlich auch mit
den Krankenhäusern zu tun Herr Minister
wir
ja im Koalitionsvertrag die sogenannten
hybrid-diagis vereinbart um eben der
ambulantisierung also die
ambulantisierung voranzutreiben meine
Frage geht dahingehend es gibt von Herrn
Professor Schreck aus Hamburg eine ein
Modell dass ich dadurch auszeichnet dass
es sehr schnell umsetzbar ist meine
Frage ist haben Sie das in Ihrer
Erwägung mit einbezogen und können wir
damit rechnen dass wir eben auch zeitnah
diese Hybrid die archies bekommen Vielen
Dank
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage dass Gutachten von Professor
schreyck auch im Auftrag des BMGS
erstellt ist mir natürlich bekannt und
im Rahmen der Vorbereitung der Maßnahme
Hybrid DLG wo es also darum geht dass
also Fallpauschalen
abgerechnet werden können in ambulante
Erbringung die bisher stationäre
Aufenthalte notwendig machen werden wir
dieses Gutachten berücksichtigen das
würde dann auch dazu führen dass
beispielsweise die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die sprechen von ärztlichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die also an der
Versorgung dieser Patienten teilnehmen
wollen diese Möglichkeit bekämen wir
müssen das System öffnen so dass also
zum einen stationäre Leistung erbracht
werden können ohne
Aufenthalt in der Klinik das jetzt
Pflegekräfte frei genauer gesagt die
Pflegekräfte werden dann dort weiter
beschäftigt sind aber nicht nur
überlastet gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
auch die ambulant tätigen Ärztinnen und
Ärzten nutzen damit sie stärker in die
stationäre Versorgung eingebunden werden
können da ist dieses von Ihnen erwähnte
Gutachten sehr wichtig und das werden
wir selbstverständlich
mitberücksichtigen
nein ich habe gesagt weil wir schon sehr
weit in der Zeit sind ich gehe jetzt
weiter in der Fragestellung
weil das war noch im weitesten Sinnen
Krankenhaus aber gestatten sie mehr
damit ich jetzt weiter in die nächste
Frage gehe weil ich glaube auch bei den
nächsten Frage wahrscheinlich sehr viele
Nachfragen kommen so dass wir in der
Zeit Weiterkommen ich habe jetzt als
nächsten Fragesteller Johannes Wagner
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister welche Stellung
messen Sie dem Vorhaben bei einem
Bundesinstitut für öffentliche
Gesundheit zu errichten und wie planen
Sie mit dem Ministerium das in dieser
Legislaturperiode noch umzusetzen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage in der Tat wir messen diesem
Vorhaben eine sehr große Bedeutung bei
weil der öffentliche Gesundheitsdienst
derzeit eine Einrichtung benötigt pro
zentral bestimmte Aufgaben übernommen
werden können die bisher nicht genau
koordiniert werden können zum Beispiel
Entwicklung von
evidenzbasierten Leitlinien für den
Öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst
Entwicklung von Softwarepaketen die hier
zuständig sind
lehrmöglichkeiten also vielleicht auch
ein Studienangebot im Öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst daher hat das eine
große Bedeutung in Deutschland fehlt
eine solche Einrichtung wir wollen eine
solche Einrichtung schaffen wir planen
das also für das nächste Jahr also
bereits also wenn wir die Vorschläge
umgesetzt bekommen die Arbeiten haben
bereits begonnen wir sind dort auch im
Austausch mit der Bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche Aufklärung die
bekannterweise zumindest in Teilen in
diese Institut übergehen soll und die
Besprechungen also finden einen
regelmäßigen Abständen statt ich kann
zusichern dass wir da entsprechenden
Regierungsentwurf ihnen vorlegen können
wahrscheinlich einen ersten Entwurf auch
noch in diesem Jahr
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank sehr geehrter Herr Minister
inwiefern könnte dieses Bundesinstitut
auch dabei helfen Prävention
voranzubringen sich ein sehr prominentes
Thema im Koalitionsvertrag in der Tat
ein solches Institut vielen Dank für die
Frage Herr Abgeordneter die an solche
Institut werden natürlich für die
Stärkung der vorbeugemedizin einen Segen
das ist ganz klar weil wir in
Deutschland ein präventionsorientiertes
Bundesinstitut derzeit nicht haben viele
dieser Aufgaben werden in hoher Qualität
vom Robert-Koch-Institut mit übernommen
aber eine eigentliche
präventionsinstitution haben wir hier
nicht da ist natürlich ein solches
Institut prädestiniert hier geht es
nicht nur um
Suchtprävention sondern auch um also
verbesserte Lebensführung hier geht es
um Vermeidung von Krebserkrankungen hier
geht es um die Integration des Wissens
wie man über Kommunikation die
Prävention also in der Bevölkerung
verbessert daher ist dieses Institut für
die Präventionsleistungen die wir uns
erwünschen einen ganz zentraler und
unabgründlicher Baustein
gibt es zu diesem Thema nachfragen
Frau Zollner
ja sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister
meine Frage wäre sie haben jetzt auch
angesprochen dass das RKI in Teilen
Aufgaben übernimmt es gibt weitere
Institutionen und vor dem Hintergrund
dass wir ja überall Anspannung haben im
Finanzierungsbereich welche weiteren
Möglichkeiten sehen Sie dann weitere
Abteilungen beispielsweise in diesem
Institut zukünftig aufgehen zu lassen
und mit welchem Stellen zu rechnen Sie
gegebenenfalls bzw in der Hoffnung dass
wir dann vielleicht schlagkräftiger
werden und tatsächlich vielleicht sogar
Stellen einsparen können
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage ich kann die präzise also
stellenplanung für dieses Institut jetzt
natürlich noch nicht vortragen weil wir
da in der Gestaltungsphase noch sind
aber ich war will auf einen Punkt hier
hinweisen der sehr bedeutsam ist weil
sie wissen daraufhin wir müssen die
Kostenentwicklung im Auge behalten es
ist tatsächlich also ein
Manko ein Problem einen Mangel in
unserem Gesundheitssystem was wir bisher
ein solches Institut nicht haben durch
die bessere Vorbeugung von schweren
Erkrankungen mit hohen Kostenfolgen
könnten wir natürlich sehr viel Geld
einsparen daher gehe ich davon aus dass
ein solches Institut sich zum Schluss
selbst finanziert durch die vermiedenen
Kosten die durch die verbesserte
vorbaubelastung erbracht werden können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank können wir dann davon
ausgehen dass sie zum Beispiel bei der
Akademisierung der Pflege die natürlich
auch einen großen Teil im Bereich der
Prävention tätig sein können endlich
einen Schritt weiterkommen und die
Kosten für die Ausbildung in diesem
Bereich übernommen werden analog der
Regelung der Hebammen Akademisierung
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat die also Kosten in der
akademisierten Pflege bleiben bei den
Studierenden hängen daher haben wir eine
viel zu geringe Anzahl von Studierenden
und das ist nicht hinzunehmen war
tatsächlich die Akademisierung der
Pflege dringend geboten ist wir
überlegen uns daher derzeit wie wir hier
eine Lösung finden so dass die
Studierenden entsprechend wirtschaftlich
so unterstützt werden dass sie nicht
schlechter gestellt sind als diejenigen
die in der Ausbildung sind da ist
beispielsweise eine fondlösung möglich
aber ich bitte Sie um Verständnis dass
wir das dass ich ihnen das heute noch
nicht sagen kann auf jeden Fall werden
wir das machen dass die Studierenden in
der Pflege
gleichgestellt sind mit den
Auszubildenden
gibt es zum Thema weitere Nachfragen
ja aus der SPD-Fraktion ich kann es
nicht ganz erkennen
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr Minister
zum Institut für öffentliche Gesundheit
hätte ich gerne die Nachfrage ob sie
vielleicht noch mal kurz skizzieren
könnten warum man solches Institut auch
wichtig wäre für die Zusammenarbeit mit
den Gesundheitsämtern der Länder und
Kreise und warum das für unser
Gesundheitssystem eine gute
Angelegenheit wäre danke
ja vielen Dank vorabgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat wir haben wir haben
derzeit das Problem dass die
Gesundheitsämter und die öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienste wenig koordiniert
sind ich bringe ein Beispiel die
Software die verwendet wird im Rahmen
der kontaktnachverfolgung im
Pandemiefall ist nicht einheitlich und
wird auch nicht einheitlich
weiterentwickelt es gibt auch in der
Fortbildung der tätigen dort also keine
einheitlichen Leitlinien so dass zum
Teil Vorgehensweise medizinisch nicht
abgestimmt ist das ist den
Gesundheitsämtern und auch den
MitarbeiterInnen und der Mitarbeiter
Gesundheitsdienstes nicht vorzuwerfen
dort wird eine vorzügliche Leistung
gebracht ich bin dankbar dass diese
Leistung im Rahmen der Pandemie aber
nicht nur dort erbracht wurde und möchte
mich anlässlich ihrer Frage auch bei
diesen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
hier noch einmal ganz herzlich bedanken
diese Leistung ist sehr viel wert von
ihr hängen wir ab trotzdem müssen wir
dem öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst auch
hier helfen zu einer zentralen
Einrichtung zu kommen wo Dinge gemacht
werden können die einzelne
Gesundheitsämter nicht machen können
dazu zählt zum Beispiel Vorbereitung der
Lehre vor Fortbildung Weiterbildung
gemeinsame Datenpakete und dergleichen
und darüber hinaus auch die Möglichkeit
sich zu akademisieren das ist alles in
diesem Institut abgebildet daher messe
ich der also Schaffung dieses Instituts
große Bedeutung bei der Verbesserung des
öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienstes in
Deutschland bei
keine Nachfrage mehr dann gehen wir
jetzt über zum nächsten Fragesteller aus
der afd-fraktion Martin sichert
Herr Minister in der Vergangenheit wurde
ja mit der Sicherheit der Impfstoffe
sehr fahrlässig umgegangen bei Astra
Seneca beispielsweise braucht es erst
Todesfälle bis man das jungen Menschen
nicht mehr empfohlen hat bis heute haben
die Impfstoffe keine vollzulassung
sondern nur eine bedingte vorläufige
Zulassung zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen
waren allein im letzten Jahr mit
Impfnebenwirkungen beim Arzt und bis
heute kennen wir die zugehörigen
Diagnosen nicht sie machen ja immer
wieder Werbung für die Impfung daher
meine Frage an Sie wollen sie für mehr
Aufklärung und Transparenz sorgen und
einen verantwortungsvolleren Umgang mit
den Impfungen um so verlorenes Vertrauen
wiederzugewinnen
ja sehr verehrter Abgeordneter vielen
Dank für die Frage zunächst einmal
möchte ich darauf hinweisen dass ich
keine Werbung für die Impfstoffe mache
sondern ich rufe Menschen zur Impfung
auf die durch die durch die Impfung
möglicherweise vor schwerer Krankheit
und vor Tod geschützt werden und das ist
die Aufgabe eines Gesundheitsministers
und möchte auch darauf hinweisen dass
diesen Impfstoffen zahlreiche Menschen
in Deutschland ihr Leben verdienen
verdanken zum zweiten also die von ihnen
in der Frage unterstellte mangelnde
Prüfung und Sicherheit der Impfstoffe
ist wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar es
gibt überhaupt keine Impfstoffe die wir
je eingesetzt haben die so gut
untersucht gewesen sind wie die derzeit
von uns eingesetzten Corona Corona ein
die die Impfstoffe sind wenn ich das
noch sagen die Impfstoffe sind
milliardenfach eingesetzt worden ja von
und wir haben dabei wir haben daher eine
präzise wir haben auch der Grundler wir
haben auf der Grundlage des
milliardenfachen Einsatzes dieser
Impfstoffe haben wir präzise Daten zu
den Nebenwirkungen dieser Impfstoffe und
auf dieser Grundlage empfehlen die
internationalen Fachgesellschaften
weltweit die Nutzung dieser Impfstoffe
vor und dem schließe ich mich auch an
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sie haben gerade gesagt dass es keine
Impfstoffe gab die so gut getestet sind
jetzt müssen momentan das was
tatsächlich jetzt hier wozu aufgerufen
wird ist ja der ba5 im Stoff und während
die Impfstoffe am Anfang wenigstens noch
an Menschen getestet worden sind bevor
man sie zugelassen hat haben wir beim
ba5 Impfstoff einen Test an 32 Mäusen
gehabt vor der Zulassung keinen Test an
Menschen halten sie wirklich 32 Mäuse
für repräsentativ für die deutsche
Bevölkerung und halten Sie das für einen
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit
Impfstoffen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete für diese
Frage die Verunsicherung der Bevölkerung
kann man so nicht stehen lassen die
die
ich entnehme ihren also Äußerungen dass
sich offenbar mit den Impfstoffen
beschäftigt haben dann wissen Sie ja
dass hier nur sehr wenige Mutationen
vorgenommen wurden dass der Impfstoff im
Wesentlichen also zu mehr als 99 Prozent
der Genom Sequenz entspricht die wir
also milliardenfach eingesetzt haben
daher gibt es wissenschaftlich keinen
Zweifel daran dass das
Nebenwirkungsprofil dieser Impfstoffe
dem Profil entspricht der Impfstoffe die
wir gut getestet haben und da und daher
ist es auf der Grundlage der
internationalen Wissenschaftler nicht
also der Fall wie sie ist hier
beschreiben die Impfstoffe die wir der
Sicherheit haben geprüft haben bei den
vorhandenen Impfstoffen dass diese
Sicherheit lässt sich auf die neuen
Impfstoffe übertragen weil sie gemessen
am genetischen Aufbau fast identisch ist
die nächste Nachfrage aus der
afd-fraktion Frau von Storch
ja vielen Dank Herr Minister habe ich
sie gerade richtig verstanden dass sie
gesagt haben es hat quasi noch nie an
Impfstoff gegeben der an so vielen
Milliarden Menschen filmt worden ist und
damit eigentlich gut getestet worden ist
haben Sie also eigentlich gesagt dass
das Ergebnis der Prüfung das ist dass
wir jetzt in der ganzen Welt sehen
können weil man ja an so vielen Menschen
quasi getestet hat haben sie das gerade
so gesagt oder wollen sie das vielleicht
kassieren denn so haben sie es gesagt
vielen Dank für die Frage vor
Abgeordnete die Antwort ist nein
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sie haben gerade gesagt Herr Professor
Dr Karl Lauterbach dass dieser Impfstoff
an Milliarden Menschen verimpft worden
ist weswegen die Erkenntnisse darüber
jetzt so groß sind aber vorher nicht
waren genau das haben sie gerade gesagt
wir werden das sicherlich gut
zusammenschneiden können aber vielleicht
können Sie das noch mal klarifizieren
damit die Menschen draußen im Land
erfahren dass sie möglicherweise
beteiligt waren an einem großen Versuch
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich will
es ihnen noch einmal erklären ich weiß
nicht ob sie es nicht verstanden haben
oder ob Sie sich hier das kann ich
wirklich nicht einschätzen ob sich hier
dümmer stellen als sie sind aber ich
werde es noch einmal erklären was ich
gesagt habe ist dass die Impfstoffe
sicher sind weil sie an sehr vielen
Menschen eingesetzt wurden nachdem sie
getestet worden und im Einsatz hat man
gesehen dass die Impfstoffe sicher sind
ich habe aber nicht gesagt dass die
Impfstoffe bei so vielen Menschen
getestet worden sind
anders anders ausgedrückt wenn aus der
aus dem Einsatz des Impfstoffes sich die
Sicherheit ergibt ist das etwas anderes
als wenn ich bei Milliarden an Impfstoff
teste
nix
nächste Nachfrage aus der afd-fraktion
Frau Dr Baum
vielen Dank Herr Lauterbach immer mehr
Ärzte und Verbände fordern die Aufhebung
der einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
auch mehrere Bundesländer haben sich
angeschlossen und das betroffene
Personal braucht unbedingt Klarheit
deshalb frage ich im Namen vieler
Mitarbeiter haben sie vor das Gesetz
auslaufen zu lassen oder wollen Sie es
verlängern
vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage wir beschäftigen uns derzeit mit
der Entwicklung der Pandemie in der also
herbst- und winterwelle und wir werden
von dem Verlauf der herbst- und
winterwelle abhängig machen wie wir mit
der einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
umgehen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen sehr
gerne Herr Lauterbach viele Menschen
haben ihnen geglaubt und darauf vertraut
dass sie das was sie immer wieder gesagt
haben dass die Impfungen keine
gesundheitlichen Schäden nach sich zieht
und haben nun zum Teil schwerste
Nebenwirkungen wie was sagen Sie diesen
davon betroffenen impfgeschädigten es
sind auch sehr viele junge Leute unter
anderem dabei was sagen Sie dem ist
jetzt von ihrer Seite endlich mal eine
Entschuldung der Entschuldigung dazu
fällig
sehr verehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich
glaube wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein darf
dass hier eine Entschuldigung fällig
wäre von Ihrer Seite wenn Sie diese
Gelegenheit nutzen die Menschen zu
verunsichern war sie stellen es hier so
da als wenn die Impfstoffe gefährlicher
wären als sie sind in Wirklichkeit
sterben Menschen wenn sie nicht geimpft
sind und es sterben Menschen wenn sie
nicht mehr ausreichend geimpft sind und
dieser Verantwortung müssten sie gerade
als ärztliche Kollegen gerecht werden
[Applaus]
nächste
Nachfrage aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen die Kollegin Heitmann
herzlichen Dank ja Herr Professor
Lauterbach nach allem was wir wissen
senkt die Impfung ja zu dem das Risiko
auch einer long kovid-erkrankung
nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir leider das
eine Reihe von Menschen deutlich länger
als die fünf bis zehn Tage die man in
Quarantäne bleibt nach einer Infektion
auch damit zu kämpfen hat deshalb an Sie
die Frage was planen Sie um die
Versorgung für die an long-erkrankten
Menschen in diesem Land zu verbessern
wollen sie da speziell auch bei den
Spezialambulanzen einen Ausbau
vorantreiben und wann es genau damit zu
rechnen
ja vielen Dank vorabgeordnete für diese
wichtige Frage in der Tat das
longkowitsch Problem haben wir im Auge
und wir unterschätzen es keineswegs der
Ausbau von Spezialambulanzen ist hier
geplant nicht nur an den
Universitätskliniken sondern auch in der
Fläche und dabei hinaus möchte ich
ankündigen werden wir auch uns also auf
den Weg machen ein Programm aufzulegen
wo die Versorgung mit also der Erhebung
von Forschungsdaten kombiniert wird weil
wir haben in Deutschland das Problem
dass wir die Versorgung verbessern
müssen aber gleichzeitig auch noch
erforschen müssen welche Versorgungswege
die besten Ergebnisse bringen und da
werden wir Ihnen in Kürze auch ein
Vorschlag machen können
bevor sie die Nachfrage ich sage das
jetzt noch mal die Nachfragen beziehen
sich auf die erste Frage und es kann
nicht sein dass hier andauernd neue
Themen aufgemacht werden weil sonst
kommen wir mit dieser Fragestunde und
dem Recht der angemeldeten Fragen hier
nicht weiter sie dürfen jetzt ihre
Nachfrage wenn es zum gleichen Thema ist
nicht mehr Stellen ich habe die jetzt
nur nicht unterbrochen weil es war
eigentlich ein anderes Thema
auch wenn es ein wichtiges Thema ist
keine Frage aber ich bitte jetzt die ich
habe nämlich noch eine lange Liste an
nachfragen und der Ursprung der Frage
war da ging es um die Impfpflicht oder
um den Impfstoff und
Arzneimittelsicherheit um genau zu sein
das war die Ursprungsfrage
immer longkowi durchaus mit der Wirkung
der Impfung auch in Zusammenhang steht
und jetzt ist der Minister auf die
Forschung auch noch mal konkret
eingegangen und auch dafür haben wir
Geld in den Haushalt eingestellt da
würde ich gerne noch mal nachfragen wo
sie da die Schwerpunkte in der Forschung
für longcovid auch setzen möchten ja
vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage
ballonkovic ist ja zunächst einmal das
Problem dass es mehrere Krankheiten
in der Ausprägung gibt die also
nebeneinander bestehen können aber es
kann auch sein dass nur eine gibt das
sind zum einen die Krankheiten die im
wesentlichen das Gehirn betreffen also
brainfog und also Erkrankungen die
darauf hinauslaufen dass unter
bestimmten Bedingungen der Patient gar
nicht mehr arbeitsfähig ist und dann
gibt es wiederum Erkrankungen die
Treffen das Lungengewebe oder den
Kreislauf wir werden in beiden Bereichen
werden wir entsprechende
forschungsmodelle vorlegen und werden
die Spezialisierung auch so aufbauen
dass es die unterschiedlichen
Digitalisierungen gibt so dass also für
beide Bereiche sind die großen Bereiche
jeweilige Ambulanzen da sind
nächste Frage stellte aus der
afd-fraktion der Kollege Brandner
aber jetzt nicht longkowitz sondern
Ursprungsthema bitte ja Ursprungsthema
selbstverständlich und um die Frage geht
es ja auch wer verunsichert wen und wer
macht Werbung für was und Herr
Lauterbach da ist mir noch im Kopf für
Ihre Äußerung von Ende letzten Jahres in
der sie prognostizierten in ihr gewohnt
sachlichen Art und Weise wie sie sowas
machen wer nicht sich wer sich nicht
impfen lässt der ist im März 2022 tot
der ist gestorben also haben sie Druck
ausgeübt das ganze sekundiert durch Jens
Spahn der sich ähnlich geäußert hat der
inzwischen für Wirtschaftspolitik
zuständig ist hoffentlich ein bisschen
erfolgreicher meine Frage noch mal sie
haben angekündigt jeder ungeimpfte ist
bis März 2022 gestorben ich bin ein
Prachtexemplar ein prachtbeispiel dafür
dass es nicht der Fall ist wie stehen
Sie zu dieser Aussage gerade vor dem
Hintergrund dass der Volksmund ja auch
sagt wer einmal lügt dem glaubt man
nicht
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter
zunächst einmal ist nicht jede falsche
Einschätzung eine Lüge und zum zweiten
ist es nicht eingetroffen und war auch
aus dem Zusammenhang gerissen jetzt von
ihnen zitiert von daher ist das eine
Aussage die ich in dieser Plattenform
noch nicht getätigt habe das ist aber
es ist aber auch also wichtig also man
muss also auch also offen miteinander
umgehen können die
Omegon Variante ist ja wesentlich
weniger tödlich verlaufend Varianten die
wir damals gehabt haben die omikon
Variante hat damals noch niemand
vorhersehen können auch niemand in ihrer
Fraktion im übrigen und das dann eine
leichte verlaufende Variante mit mehr
Ansteckung aber einem deutlich
geringeren Risiko zu versterben bekommen
haben darüber können wir alle froh sein
somit wenn ich mich in der Prognose irre
weil eine Variante kommt die weniger
gefährlich ist dann bin ich dafür
dankbar und korrigiere mich gerne
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
schön dass Sie die fehlereinschätzung
einräumen aber wir gucken noch mal
zurück als sie diese Äußerungen getan
haben jeder ungeimpfte ist bis März 2022
gestorben waren etwa 20 30 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland ungeimpft das an
das heißt sie als Fachpolitiker haben
2030 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
gesagt ihr werdet sterben wenn ihr euch
nicht impfen lasst jetzt werden sich
wahrscheinlich viele ich hoffe nicht
allzu viele von ihrer Expertise haben
beeinflussen lassen die haben sich
gesunde Menschen haben sich impfen
lassen und waren danach durch die
Impfung krank ist es da nicht jetzt mal
an der Zeit sich dafür zu entschuldigen
dass sie Leute wissen nicht in Impfungen
gejagt haben die da hinterher erkrankt
sind nicht an der Krankheit sondern an
der Impfung allen Folgen der Impfung
Abgeordneter ich habe es so nicht gesagt
wie es jetzt hier unterstellt haben und
von daher kann ich auch Ihre Frage nicht
beantworten
nächste Frage zu diesem Thema aus der
afd-fraktion der Kollege
dietzi wann Ziegler okay
vielen Dank Herr Minister ich habe
folgende Frage an Sie sie sagen ja die
ganze Zeit die Impfstoffe sind sicher
und sie sind verträglich und sie sorgen
dafür dass weniger Leute ins Krankenhaus
kommen ihre Staatssekretär hat heute im
Gesundheitsausschuss folgende Aussage
gemacht die
ospedalisierungsinsidenz Index liegt im
Moment bei 12 von 100.000 Einwohnern im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr zum selben
Zeitpunkt der lacht der
hospitalisierungsindex bei 1,7 erklären
Sie mir bitte wie das mit diesen
Impfstoffen einhergeht wie der
hospitalisierungsindex so ansteigen
konnte wenn denn die Impfstoffe
vernünftig wirken würden vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage in der Tat ist es so dass wir
derzeit eine bedrückende Zunahme der
Patientinnen und Patienten in den
Kliniken auch auf der Intensivstation
beobachten ich habe daher eben darauf
hingewiesen dass die Länder jetzt also
eine Pflicht sind die Maßnahmen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes zu prüfen und
anzuwenden die Tatsache dass derzeit
sehr viele Menschen erkranken weil sie
sich infiziert haben legt also an der
mangelnden Vorsicht und legt Licht an
den Impfstoffen wenn die Impfstoffe
nicht im Einsatz wären dann würden diese
Verläufe die wir derzeit beobachten ganz
anders ausgehen das heißt wir haben im
Moment zwar eine hohe
hospitalisierungsinsidenz aber die Zahl
der Todesfälle ist deutlich niedriger
als wir sie vor einem Jahr gehabt haben
und das verdanken wir der Wirkung der
Impfstoffe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
uns wird seit mehr als zwei Jahren
erzählt dass die Impfstoffe vor schweren
Verläufen schützen wenn man in ein
Krankenhaus kommt und diese der Index
ist deutlich höher als in den Vorjahren
dann verstehe ich nicht wie das mit
diesen
Impfstoffen überhaupt möglich ist das
ist meine Frage wieso ist das möglich
wenn die Impfstoffe so wirksam sind dass
die Leute trotzdem im Krankenhaus landen
und im Krankenhaus landen bedeutet ja es
ist ein schwerer Verlauf zumindest in
meinem logischen Verständnis das bitte
da hätte ich gerne bitte eine Erklärung
dafür vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete ich
glaube ich kann diese Frage beantworten
der Unterschied liegt darin dass es an
Unterschied macht ob ich in einem
Krankenhaus komme und werde dort
erfolgreich behandelt oder ob ich ein
Krankenhaus komme und verstärke und die
Impfstoffe die im nass werden mehr
gestorben verstaucht sie dürfen sich
nicht dümmer stellen als sie sind es mag
nicht leicht sein aber die sie die
Menschen kommen jetzt in die
Krankenhäuser hinein und überleben die
Erkrankung weil sie geimpft sind und
wenn sie nicht geimpft wären dann wäre
der Verlauf sehr viel schwerer und es
würden mehr Menschen versterben
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen die Kollegen
kühnerst
gar nicht vielleicht ist es Dummheit
oder vielleicht sogar Absicht also ich
weiß jetzt nicht weil sie gesagt haben
manche stellen sich dümmer als Sie
vielleicht sind es kann auch Absicht
sein ich stelle in dieser Runde fest wie
menschenverachtend Leute Kollegen hier
sein können die mit Zahlen operieren
nach Motto es sind nicht 100 sondern nur
zwölf auf der Intensivstation ich frage
mich bei manchen was ist eigentlich in
ihrem Leben schiefgegangen dass in diese
12 Leute sowas von egal sind und im
Minister möchte ich fragen
der Minister möchte ich fragen wir reden
ja über das Impfen und die Frage der
Risiken natürlich hat jede jeder
Impfstoff auch ein Risiko andere gibt
sich aber er hat auch eine Chance und
ich würde gerne mal von Ihnen wissen wie
sie das denn abwägen Risiko und Chancen
bei Impfstoffen in Relation gesetzt zu
Risiken und Chancen wenn man nicht
geimpft ist ich persönlich kenne auch
Leute die geimpft werden und krank
wurden die lange krank sind danach aber
Verantwortung und Vorsorgeprinzip heißt
ja dass in Relation zu setzen
ja vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage
und in der Tat ich kann hier nur zum
Beispiel verweisen auf die Empfehlung
der Ständigen Impfkommission die den
über 60-Jährigen jetzt die
Vervollständigung des Impfschutzes
empfiehlt weil aus der Perspektive der
ständigen Inflation dort der Nutzen der
Impfung den Risiken der Impfung der
Nutzen überwiegt das Risiko der Impfung
erwarten es ist einfach so und weil dem
so ist weil weil dem so ist das hängt
immer von natürlich vom Einzelnen ab das
Alter Spiel eine Rolle ob Risikofaktor
aber für alle über 60-Jährigen wird
jetzt beispielsweise durch die sticko
die vierte Impfung auch mit den
angepassten Impfstoffen empfohlen weil
man davon ausgeht dass für alle über
60-Jährigen der Nutzen der Impfung
größer ist als das Risiko sich impfen zu
lassen das gilt auch für diejenigen die
unter 60 sind und Risikofaktoren haben
wir haben ähnliche Einschätzungen durch
Expertenkommissionen in der ganzen Welt
also in fast allen europäischen Ländern
auch in osteuropäischen Ländern in den
Vereinigten Staaten in England diese
Empfehlungen gelten in der gesamten Welt
somit kann ich es wirklich nicht
verstehen dass die internationale
Wissenschaft hier im Haus immer wieder
hinterfragt wird ich weiß nicht woher
diese Spezialkenntnisse kommen können
keine Nachfrage ich lasse jetzt noch
zwei Nachfragen zu zu diesem Thema
auch wenn noch mehr Wortmeldungen sind
Frau von ich lasse noch zwei zu und ich
sage auch jetzt schon dass diese
Befragung zum Leidwesen des Ministers um
eine Viertelstunde verlängert wird damit
wir noch annähernd durch die
angemeldeten Fragen kommen ich habe
jetzt noch zwei einmal den Herrn
Reichert aus der afd-fraktion und dann
ist die Kollegin gleich aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion auch noch dran
ich muss da noch mal nachfragen sie
haben vorhin auf die Frage des Kollegen
sichert dass die neuen Impfstoffe mit 32
Mäusen getestet worden sind
gesagt dass das daran lege dass der
alte Impfstoff und der neue vom Genom
her zu 99% übereinstimmen nun ist es
aber auch so dass das Genom von Menschen
und Schimpansen zu 97 bis 99 Prozent
übereinstimmt ich kann da nicht erkennen
wo sie da dann diese Leichtfertigkeit
hernehmen Minister könnten sie dazu
vielleicht was sagen
sehr geehrter Abgeordneter ich glaube
das ist das also brauche ich nicht zu
beantworten die also Wirkstoffe die hier
miteinander verglichen werden das sind
ja genome die sich ausschließlich auf
die Impfwirkung beziehen und beim
menschlichen genomen wie auch beim
Schimpansen genommen und beim tierischen
genommen gibt es sehr große Strecken die
in keiner Weise beispielsweise sogar
auch nur eine funktionelle Bedeutung
haben wenn sich damit auskennen eben
Genom sind große Strecken die im
Wesentlichen also weder also die mit die
Mexikaner physiologischen Eigenschaft an
hergehen somit sind diese Vergleiche
zwischen den Spezies und den Wirkstoffen
vollkommen irrelevant
sie dürfen einen Nachfrage stellen
das ist nicht der Fall dann ist jetzt
die Kollegin Borchert aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
dank frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Herr
Minister sie haben ja bereits jetzt
mehrfach erwähnt dass sie sich von der
STIKO beraten lassen sehen Sie es mir
nach dass es nicht immer die Eindruck
den ich im Gesundheitsausschuss gewinnen
konnte sie haben Aussagen zur
Auffrischungsimpfung getätigt die im
Widerspruch zur offiziellen Empfehlung
der STIKO standen warum haben sie für
diese Verunsicherung gesorgt und glauben
Sie dass dies die Impfbereitschaft
fördert und auch zu mehr Glaubwürdigkeit
führt vielen Dank ja vielen Dank Frau
Abgeordnete für diese Frage wir haben
die sticko erweitert um beratende
Mitglieder so dass wir dort eine weitere
Institution ergänzend geschaffen haben
die sogenannte paiko die Pandemie
Impfkommission dieser Impfkommission
wohne ich selbst bei und wir diskutieren
im Einvernehmen miteinander wir sind
keine
Missverständnisse oder
Meinungsverschiedenheiten in dieser also
Zusammenarbeit bekannt und die Arbeit
der STIKO hat einen gewohnt hohes Niveau
und jeder von uns als besonders
Ministerium voll unterstützt
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
dass das nicht der Fall dann gehe ich
jetzt über in die nächste angemeldete
Frage der SPD-Fraktion Heike Behrens
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister so wie sie und
auch andere renommierte Expertinnen und
Experten ist ja immer wieder angekündigt
haben steigen eben die
corona-infektionszahlen spürbar und die
jüngsten Entwicklungen insbesondere in
Bayern nach dem Oktoberfest führen in
den Kliniken jetzt schon zu sehr
belastenden Situationen nicht nur für
das Personal sondern vor allem auch für
die Menschen die eben in diesen
Krankenhäusern behandelt werden müssen
werden Ihrer Meinung nach die Länder
ihrer
ausführungsverantwortung im Rahmen des
Infektionsschutzes ausreichend gerecht
auch wenn Sie zum Beispiel teilweise die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht in der
Umsetzung sehr lachshandhaben und welche
ergänzenden Schritte planen Sie
gegebenenfalls für die Bundesregierung
damit wir gut durch den Herbst Winter
kommen
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage in der Tat ist es so dass
die Länder zum Teil sehr schwer
nachvollziehbare Ratschläge dann auch
öffentlich geben ich bin zum Beispiel
aus Süddeutschland zum Teil kritisiert
worden für einen nicht ausreichend
strenge Handhabung im Infektionsschutz
das ist etwas was ich eher seltener als
häufiger höre aber immerhin aber das ist
ja nicht der springende Punkt sondern
zum Talgrund an dieser Ratschläge auch
mit dem Maßkrug in der Hand vorgetragen
und hatten daher geringe Glaubwürdigkeit
ich glaube dass die Länder jetzt gut
beraten sind sich den Infektionsverlauf
genau anzuschauen also
Infektionsschutzgesetz gibt hier die
Möglichkeiten und ich glaube es ist eine
Fehlannahme zu glauben dass die jetzt
beginnen der Herbst und winterwelle sich
von alleine begrenzt das glaube ich
nicht dass der stattfinden wird daher
würde ich mir wünschen dass die Länder
jetzt prüfen wann der optimale Zeitpunkt
ist auch Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und ich
hoffe dass wir mit sind dann auch gut
zusammenarbeiten können davon gehe ich
aber auch aus bei der Verbesserung des
Schließens der Impflücken in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen bei den älteren
Menschen da arbeiten wir sehr eng mit
dem Hausärzteverband zusammen ich möchte
mich ausdrücklich übrigens beim Hausarzt
zuverband hier auch für die
Zusammenarbeit bei der Vorbereitung der
Impfkampagne aber auch bei der
Vorbereitung der besseren Versorgung mit
also Medikamenten bei den Betroffenen
bedanken also das ist etwas was wir
gemeinsam schaffen ich glaube wir müssen
nach vorne blicken wenn wir nach vorne
blicken Länder bunt
hausärzteschaft Pflegeeinrichtungen wir
können das schaffen wir sind besser
vorbereitet als im letzten Jahr und
haben alle Möglichkeiten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
diese Gelegenheit nehme ich gerne wahr
Herr mir ist da sie haben vorher schon
die internationale Dimensionen der
Pandemie angesprochen und deshalb möchte
ich noch mal nachfragen wenn sie jetzt
blicken auf unseren Nachbarländer wer
hat welche Maßnahmen vielleicht besser
umsetzen können als wir und Wo können
wir uns ein Vorbild nehmen um eben
besser durch Herbst und Winter kommen zu
können
vielen Dank für die Frage vorabgeordnete
also mir liegt es fern andere Länder zu
bewerten oder anderen Ländern Ratschläge
zu geben ich glaube wir können insgesamt
mit der Art und Weise wie wir die
Pandemie bisher gemanagt haben zu
einigermaßen zufrieden sein weil wir
gemessen an zum Beispiel anderen
europäischen Ländern eine Sterblichkeit
erreichen konnten die ungefähr halb so
hoch ist somit wir sind eigentlich nicht
perfekt aber besser durch die Pandemie
bisher gekommen als viele unserer
Nachbarländer ich will einfach alles tun
was in meiner Macht steht damit es nicht
schlechter wird sondern besser
gibt es zum Thema eine Nachfrage das ist
nicht der Fall dann gehe ich zur
nächsten angemeldeten Frage die Kollegin
Katrin Vogler von aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister
ich würde jetzt gerne mal zu einem
brennenden Thema kommen auch im
Zusammenhang mit Inflation und Teuerung
es ist ja so dass wir bei der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung ein
enormes Defizit haben wo sie immer
betonen dass es im Wesentlichen von
ihrem Vorgänger geerbt ist der teure
leistungsreform gemacht hat und von
Strukturreformen Abstand genommen habe
allerdings war natürlich auch die SPD
Teil dieser Regierung und sie als
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion zuständig für
Gesundheitspolitik das heißt also dass
sie das auch ein bisschen mit zu
verantworten haben und jetzt kommt halt
leider aus ihrem Haus keine
Strukturreform die die Sicherung der
Krankenkassen nachhaltig gewährleistet
stattdessen haben sie jetzt den
Bundestag ein Notpaket vorgelegt das zum
größten Teil die Rücklagen der
krankenkassenverbraucht und das
Gesundheitsfonds dass die
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
mindestens noch mal mit fünf Milliarden
durch beitragssatzsteigerungen belastet
und dass der GKV einen Milliarden redet
von der Bundesregierung aufzwingt wo er
niemals weiß wer wieder zurückgezahlt
werden kann also da möchte ich wissen
wann ist denn sind denn jetzt endlich
von ihnen wirkliche Strukturreformen zu
erwarten beispielsweise in dem die
einnahmensbasis der gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen verbreitert wird und mehr
Menschen mit höheren Einkommen
einbezogen werden etwa durch Anhebung
der beitragsbemessungs- und der
Pflichtversicherungsgrenze
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete ich
glaube wenn ich Frage richtig verstehe
verwechseln Sie eine Strukturreform mit
einer Finanzreform sie haben daran nach
Strukturreform gefragt und haben dann
gesagt wann kommt denn mehr Geld ins
System aber mehr Geld ins System ist ja
keine Strukturreform die Strukturreform
das sind die Dinge die ich eben
angesprochen habe diese zwölf Gesetze
die ich also eben angekündigt habe von
der Art und Weise über die
Kinderheilkunde demnächst finanzieren
für die Geburtshilfe finanzieren wie wir
Anreize setzen für
tagesfahrtpauschalen wie wir das
fahrpauschalen System weiterentwickeln
wie wir die Digitalisierung durch die
elektronische Patientenakte verbessern
wie wir das elektronische Rezept
verändern wie wir die gesundheitskioske
für die Bedürftigen Bereiche machen und
so weiter das Krankenpflege
entlastungsgesetz das sind alles
Strukturreformen weil sie verbessern die
Art und Weise wie die Medizin gemacht
wird ich mache es ganz simpel bessere
und effizientere gesehen auch durch eine
endökonomisierung im Krankenhaussektor
das was davon abzugrenzen ist ist die
Frage wie wird das System bezahlt die
Bezahlung ist ja keine Strukturreform da
haben wir in der ersten Runde jetzt
erstmal Effizienzreserven gehoben der
Beitragssatz wird darüber hinaus im 0,3
Beitragssatzpunkte erhöht das gibt einen
Steuerzuschuss von zusätzlichen zwei
Milliarden ein Darlehen aber es ist ganz
klar dass weitere finanzierungsreformen
in dieser Legislaturperiode folgen wird
folgen müssen und daher also kommen die
finanzreformen aber jetzt ist erstmal
die effizienzreserve gehoben worden und
die Strukturreformen habe ich eben mit
den 12 Beispielen benannt
Möglichkeit eine Nachfrage
ja vielen Dank Herr Minister auch wenn
ich vielleicht Struktur und Finanzierung
verwechselt habe ist es doch so dass
diese 12 Reformvorhaben die Sie gerade
genannt haben werden nicht unmittelbar
zur Entlastung der beitragszahlerinnen
und Beitragszahler werden beitragen und
auch nicht dazu unmittelbar die
Versorgung effizienter und schlanker zu
gestalten sondern im Gegenteil dass die
erstmal finanziert werden müssen also
Beispiel die gesundheitskioske die sie
auch genannt haben die finde ich
tatsächlich durchaus
ein spannendes Programm wo es halt darum
geht dass gerade in ländlichen Räumen
und im benachteiligten Stadtteilen
Versorgung verbessert werden soll aber
so etwas kostet doch sie wollen tausend
Gesundheits-
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage die gesundheitskioske werden
insgesamt ihr die GKV entlasten war das
ja eine Versorgung in den ärmsten
Stadtteilen wo die Patienten die keinen
Zugangssystem haben oft über die
Notfallambulanzen dann aufgenommen
werden und dann oft übrigens dann sogar
stationär versorgt werden müssen hier
kann man doch durch einfache Mittel
verhindern dass eine Krankheit die durch
also kleine Interventionen noch
behandelbar ist beispielsweise in dem
die Blutdruckmedikamente eingenommen
werden zu einer schweren Krankheit der
dann stattfinde Schlaganfall wird
gesundheitskioske sind ein Beispiel
dafür wo eine neue Struktur mehr Geld
spart als was sie kostet
vielen Dank wir haben einige Nachfragen
und es beginnt der abrundesorge
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister sie haben
gerade auf die Frage des finanzdefizits
mehr oder weniger ausweichend
geantwortet und wir haben ja nun dieses
Defizit in Höhe von prognostizierten 17
Milliarden Euro fürs nächste Jahr die
nächsten Jahre dann voraussichtlich
sogar noch höher und deshalb meine Frage
sie haben ja in der Vergangenheit
ausgeschlossen dass quasi 10 Milliarden
die im System ja fehlen weil die
Beiträge die Krankenkassenbeiträge für
alg2-bezieher aus dem Bundeshaushalt
nicht in ordnungsgemäßer Höhe abgeführt
werden in den gesundheitsformen dass Sie
darauf verzichten werden das heißt sie
Unternehmen überhaupt nicht den Versuch
beim Bundesfinanzminister die Mittel die
ja dem Gesundheitssystem zustehen wird
in Höhe von 10 Milliarden dort
einzufordern und deshalb würde mich
interessieren ob sie ernsthaft glauben
dass sie diese 17 Milliarden Defizit mit
Effizienz Reserven im System so wie sie
es ja immer sagen
ja kompensiert bekommen und gleichzeitig
die Akteure im System Ärzte apothe
Pharmaindustrie forschende Unternehmen
zusätzlich belasten wollen
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter möchte
ich noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
ich dieses Defizit bekanntlicherweise
von meinem Vorgänger geerbt habe zum
zweiten sie werden sehen durch den
abstimmungsverlauf sie werden sehen
durch den abstimmungsverlauf hier im
Haus dass wir dieses Defizit bereinigen
können durch das Heben von
Effizienzreserven und zum dritten ich
habe nicht gesagt dass ich also auf die
Erhöhung der Beiträge für
Arbeitslosengeld 2 Empfänger oder die
Dynamisierung des Bundeszuschusses dass
ich darauf verzichten werde aber nur bei
einer Veranstaltung darauf hingewiesen
dass wir das jetzt nicht machen müssen
sondern dass das im Laufe der
Legislaturperiode stattfinden muss aber
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt können wir das
bestehende Defizit beheben durch die
Effizienzreserven die im System noch
bestehen und das werden sie quasi der
Abstimmungsergebnisse hier im Haus bald
sehen
gibt es noch eine Nachfrage
natürlich habe ich noch eine Nachfrage
dazu das ist ja im Grunde das Herr
Minister was sie die letzten Monate
quasi mantraartig vor sich her tragen
dass sie sagen alle Probleme die das
Gesundheitssystem in Deutschland hat
hätten sie von ihrem Vorgänger geerbt
also es ist ja bereits schon angeklungen
oder ich kann mich dunkel erinnern dass
sie in der letzten Legislatur ja als
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
ja ja das tut weh ja tut weh ich weiß
dass sie als Stellvertreter
Fraktionsvorsitzender ja für den
Gesundheitsbereich zuständig waren und
insofern insofern würde mich schon mal
interessieren ob der damalige
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz und
jetzige Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz der
diese 10 Milliarden immer gedeckelt hat
und nicht abführen wollte ob Sie der
Meinung sind dass das richtig war
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete ich habe
nie gesagt soll ich meine Meinung dass
man Vorgänger alles falsch gemacht hat
das ist nicht meine Meinung und das
würde ich auch nicht vortragen aber
lediglich auf dieses Defizit hier
abgehoben und das werde ich beseitigen
mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im
Haus zusammen dann das werden wir durch
Effizienz Reserven beseitigen und wie es
dann mit der weitergehenden Finanzierung
unseres Gesundheitssystems sich
entwickelt das werden wir im nächsten
Jahr dann gemeinsam entwickeln wir
werden also die Strukturreformen machen
die 12 Gesetze die ich eben beschrieben
habe wir werden eine Finanzreform machen
und wir werden das Defizit beseitigen es
wird alles gelingen also an allen drei
Blöcken werden wir erfolgreich arbeiten
also Effizienz Reserven
Strukturreformen und Finanzreform alle
drei Blöcke werden abgearbeitet und zwar
erfolgreich
dann habe ich eine Nachfrage der Kollege
Lüdtke
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister natürlich hängt
es Defizit in der Krankenversicherung
auch mit den Versäumnissen bei
Strukturreformen da Vorgängerregierungen
zusammen ich bin deswegen sehr froh dass
wir diese jetzt endlich angehen was
genau haben Sie vor um die
ambulantisierung voranzutreiben und
welche Rolle sollen niedergelassene
Ärzte und andere therapieberufe in dem
Zusammenhang spielen
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage in der Tat wir wollen in der
im Bereich der stationären Versorgung
etwas einführen was in vielen anderen
europäischen Ländern schon gelungen ist
dass die fahrpauschalen Leistung also
die Leistung die stationär gebracht wird
das Jahr erbracht werden kann in dem auf
die Übernachtung verzichtet wird das
kann man mit dem Begriff tagesdealg
beschreiben auf jeden Fall führt das
dazu dass dort massiv bei der Pflege
entlastet werden kann man kann
allerdings auch Leistungen die bisher
stationär erbracht worden komplett
ambulant erbringen und da sind natürlich
auch die niedergelassenen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen gefordert dass sie sich
dort einbringen sie alle kennen den
aop-katalog da könnte man sich
vorstellen dass wir diesen Katalog der
ja vorliegt stärker ausweitend in die
Versorgung einbringen wir können es uns
nicht länger leisten dass wir die
ambulanten und die stationären Bereiche
gegeneinander stellen sondern hier muss
miteinander gearbeitet werden das
verbessert die Effizienz der Versorgung
die Versorgungsqualität und das auch die
einzige Art und Weise wie wir den Mangel
in der Zukunft begegnen können haben sie
eine Nachfrage
Stellungnahme der Regierungskoalition
Kommission zum Bereich die jetzt
vorliegt zum Bereich ambulantisierung
ist das für sie ein gangbarer Weg die
Maßnahmen die dort aufgezeigt worden
sind die Stellungnahme der
Regierungskommission ist von uns mit
großem Wohlwollen aufgenommen worden und
das was wir in den nächsten Monaten
entwickeln werden die Arbeit hat ja
längst begonnen wird sich also sehr eng
an dem orientieren was die
Regierungskommission vorgetragen hat es
sind ja immer mehrere Optionen auch
vorgetragen worden wir werden die Option
wählen die politisch am besten und am
effizientesten durchsetzbar ist
so das war die doch sehr interessante
Befragung der Bundesregierung mit dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister mit Karl
Lauterbach gegen 15 Uhr melden wir uns
hier wieder wenn es dann eine Aktuelle
Stunde gibt zu den Vorschlägen der
Expertenkommission zur gaspreisbremse
jetzt geht es aber erstmal weiter mit
meiner Kollegin Ines Arland in Bonn
vielen Dank Janet Knaack also wir kehren
zu Ihnen zurück in ungefähr 60 Minuten
zuvor bieten wir Ihnen meine Damen und
Herren etwas akklima übrigens eine
Strukturreform gewesen eine
Bürgerversicherung einzuführen ist mehr
als noch eine Finanzreform das kann man
schon Strukturreform nennen aber das
haben sie jetzt diese Legislatur
anscheinend nicht mehr vor und nicht
geschafft aber vielleicht kommen wir zum
Versprechen von ihm von früher und zwar
haben sie im Frühjahr angekündigt dass
wir in einen europäischen Ländern die
eine Idee wäre Arzneimittel nur ein auf
Arzneimittel Nord ermäßigten
Mehrwertsteuersatz gelten zu lassen
manchmal sogar nur zwei oder null
Prozent in Deutschland gilt nach wie vor
der voller Mehrwertsteuersatz wieso
versuchen Sie es nicht so wie bei
Tierarzt neue Mitteln aber auch
stadionbesuchender Schnittblumen dass
man da vielleicht ein geringerer
Mehrwertsteuersatz einführt warum haben
sie ihre Meinung geändert diese noch im
Frühjahr hatten und werden sie es
vielleicht jetzt doch noch mal mit dem
Finanzminister in Verbindung setzen wenn
er 200 Milliarden insgesamt in die in
die Hand zu nehmen ist es vielleicht
auch dort anzuwenden denn es wäre ja bei
so einem doppelwumms möglich danke schön
ja vielen Dank für diese Frage ich
möchte noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
also die also
verfügbar machen von mehr Geld für das
System also mehr Steuern oder mehr also
höherer Krankenkassenbeitrag oder höhere
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze einfach mehr
gelten das System wir nehmen das mehr
Geld und bringen es in das existierende
System das ist keine Strukturreform das
ist und weniger Geld ist auch keine
Strukturreform also man muss
unterschaden zwischen einer
Strukturreform und der Finanzierung des
Systems und Strukturreformen sind die
Dinge die ich eben beschrieben habe
krankenhausreform arzneimittelreform wie
wir die Kinderheilkunde bezahlen zum
Beispiel die gesundheitskioske was die
Kollegin angesprochen hat wie gehen wir
hier weiter mit diesem Institut für
öffentliches Gesundheitswesen das sind
echte schwierige Strukturreformen ich
sage das auch deshalb wenn man solche
Reformen macht dann muss man sich mit
vielen also ja sagen wir Lobbygruppen im
Gesundheit trotzdem auseinandersetzen
weil jede Strukturreform hat Gewinner
und Verlierer mehr Geld in die Hand zu
nehmen es bleibt zum Schluss ich will
nur sagen mehr Geld in die Hand zu
nehmen hier habt ihr mehr Geld und es
bleibt so wie immer das kann jeder das
ist kann nicht unser Ansatz sein sie
haben noch eine Möglichkeit der
Nachfrage okay ich mache es mal ganz
konkret weil die Frage gar nicht
beantwortet haben und sonst auf übrigens
der falschen Ansicht des Begriffs
Strukturreform hingewiesen haben die
Frage lautet möchten Sie die auf
Arzneimittel in Zukunft nicht doch einer
mäßigten Mehrwertsteuersatz anwenden wie
es im Frühjahr noch selbst behauptet
haben
ich habe nichts behauptet sondern ich
habe diese Maßnahme erörtert damals und
wir haben sie auch mit den Ländern
erörtert und die Länder sind hier ja
unmittelbar von den Einnahmen betroffen
und waren an einer solchen Reform bisher
nicht interessiert kein Land im übrigen
also auch kein Land wo der
Ministerpräsident beispielsweise durch
die Partei DIE LINKE gestellt wird
vielen Dank Herr Minister dann kommen
wir zur nächsten und zur letzten
regulären Frage der Abgeordneten Nicole
westing
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister der wissenschaftliche Beirat
beim Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat
kürzlich sein Gutachten für eine
nachhaltige Reform der
Pflegeversicherung
veröffentlicht mit ganz klaren
Empfehlungen für die dringend
notwendigere Form gerade mit Blick auf
die Generationengerechtigkeit im
Koalitionsvertrag haben wir geplant eine
Expertenkommission dazu einzusetzen
welche Reformschritte planen Sie genau
und wann wird diese Expertenkommission
eingesetzt vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete
für diese Frage wir werden im nächsten
Jahr uns mit der Finanzierung der Pflege
auseinandersetzen wir werden bis dahin
eine Reform vortragen die die
Pflegeversicherung absichert bis zur
Mitte des nächsten Jahres so dass also
wir kann Defizit haben die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung hat ja ein Defizit
von 17 Milliarden Euro das wird durch
das Gesetz was wir hier
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz genannt
demnächst beschließen werden beseitigt
wir haben ein kleiner Office sind aber
doch ein nennenswertes Defizit von etwas
weniger als drei Milliarden zu erwarten
in der Pflegeversicherung bis zum Mitte
des nächsten Jahres auch dafür werden
wir Ihnen in kürzer einen Vorschlag
unterbreiten wie das beseitigt wird aber
dann muss eine Finanzierungsreform der
Pflegeversicherung kommen und da werden
wir auf eine gutachterliche Begleitung
zurückgreifen
aber könnte man nicht jetzt auch nach
der Veröffentlichung des Gutachtens
direkt diese Expertenkommission
einsetzen
vielen Dank für die Nachfrage für
Abgeordnete das könnten wir machen es
würde aber wenig Sinn machen weil wir
müssen erst mal schauen wie die
Einnahmensituation sich entwickelt und
ich muss erst einmal die Defizite die
ich sag mal ich muss mich etwas
vorsichtiger ausdrücken von der
Vorgängerregierung geehrt habe diese
Defizite muss ich erst einmal beseitigen
und dann kommen die großen
finanzierungsreserven
finanzierungsreformen aber in der in dem
Dreiklang Strukturreform sofort
defizitbeseitigung auch sofort und dann
Finanzierungsreform im nächsten Jahr in
diesem Dreiklang gehen wir vor und das
ist auch die richtige Reihenfolge erst
musste die Strukturreform kommen die
Defizite müssen behoben sein und dann
kommt eine wirklich durchdachte also
Finanzierungsreform im nächsten Jahr
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen da jetzt
eine Anhörung im Gesundheitsausschuss
ansteht und mir schon viele signalisiert
haben dass sie sozusagen auf heißen
Kohlen deshalb sitzen würde ich an
dieser Stelle die Fragestunde beenden
und keine weiteren Nachfragen zulassen
herzlichen Dank und den
Gesundheitspolitikern viel Erfolg bei
der Anhörung und
ich beende damit die Befragung und wir
kommen in zum Tagesordnungspunkt 2 der
Fragestunde
die mündlichen Fragen auf Drucksache 20
38 58 werden in der üblichen
Reihenfolge aufgerufen
und ich rufe auf den Geschäftsbereich
des Bundesministeriums der Finanzen und
zur Beantwortung steht bereit die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin Katja
Hessel ich rufe auf die Frage Nummer
eins des Abgeordneten Tobias Matthias
Peterka zum Thema geplante Maßnahmen zur
finanziellen Entlastung von Autofahrern
im Herbst und Winter liebe Frau
Staatssekretärin vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin die Frage des Abgeordneten
beantworte ich wie folgt die
Bundesregierung hat seit Februar drei
große entlastungspakete mit einem
Gesamtvolumen von mehr als 95 Milliarden
Euro auf den Weg gebracht hinzu kommt
der am 29 September angekündigte
abwehrshire mit einem Volumen von 200
Milliarden Euro der als zentrales
Element die gaspreisbremse finanzieren
soll diese gaspreisbremse wird allen
VerbraucherInnen Verbrauchern sowie
Unternehmen helfen die von stark
angestiegenen Gaspreisen betroffen sind
dazu gehört im Übrigen auch die
Reifenindustrie die dadurch ihre
Produktionskosten senken kann die
Bundesregierung hat mit dem bisherigen
bislang beschlossene Maßnahmen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in ganz
erheblichen Umfang entlastet der Staat
kann aber nicht alle Belastungen
abfedern die durch erhöhte Preise auf
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zukommen
sie haben die Möglichkeit von nachfragen
ja vielen Dank für diese recht
allgemeine Antwort es hat ja erstmal
hier von mir die Stoßrichtungen gehabt
49 Euro Ticket also nachfolge-ticket des
neuen euro-tickets man hat sich jetzt
wohl geeinigt dass es in dem Bereich
eben 50 bis 70 euro liegen wird aber
weiterhin ja auch schlussendlich ein
klimaticket darstellt also es wird hier
und das ist meine Nachfrage
offensichtlich der Autofahrer und das
Auto als weitaus verbreitetes und
beliebtestes Verkehrsmittel wird das
hier quasi absichtlich ausgenommen also
die Formulierung klimaticket deutet ja
darauf hin
die Bundesregierung hat sich zum Ziel
genommen die Klimawende mit zu
beschleunigen den Klima entgegen also
dem klimaausbau entgegenzukommen und
hiermit mit freundlich anders gehen Sie
wissen wir haben 1,5 Milliarden auch für
die Nachfolge des 9-euro-tickets als
Bundesregierung mit zur Verfügung
gestellt ja wir haben aber auch im
Entlastungspaket Nummer eins die
fernpendlerpauschale bereits erhöht also
es ist nicht so dass hier der Autofahrer
ausgeklammert oder benachteiligt wird
sie haben die Möglichkeit eine zweite
Nachfrage zu stellen die
Pendlerpauschale wurde meiner Meinung
nach nur glatt gezogen und dann stellen
wir fest es gibt zum Beispiel eben keine
Pauschale für Winterreifen gut aber auch
ansonsten die Ausführungen von ihnen
gerade eben die sonstigen Entlastungen
sind meiner Meinung nach eher punktuell
gaspreisbremse kann man halten was man
will davon aber ich sehe zum Beispiel
keine Ansätze für sonstige
heizalternativen Pellets Holz
im engeren Sinne das haben sie dann wohl
hier ausgeklammert wiederum oder
wir haben mit dem Entlastungspaket 1 2
und 3 erhebliche Entlastungen für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gebracht in
vielen vielen Bereichen gerade möchte
ich noch mal auf den Heizkostenzuschuss
auch angeben auf die Erweiterung des
Wohngeldes also es ist hier auch viel
getan worden um allen Bürgern zu helfen
die gaspreisbremse wird jetzt
hauptsächlich natürlich den gasben
kommen das liegt im Namen der Kollege
aber wir wissen auch dass die Gaspreis
der Gaspreis auch extrem angestiegen ist
wesentlich mehr als die anderen Preise
gibt es aus den anderen Fraktionen
nachfragen
zum Thema das ist nicht der Fall dann
fahren wir fort mit der zweiten Frage
der Abgeordneten Dr Ingeborg Grässle
Gründe für die Errichtung eines
bundesfinanzkriminalamtes Frau
Staatssekretärin sie haben das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die Frage
der Kollegin darf ich wie folgt
beantworten der Vorschlag des
Bundesministers auf Bundesfinanzminister
sieht vor in einer neuen
Bundesoberbehörde zu Bekämpfung von
Finanzkriminalität in drei Säulen alle
relevanten Zuständigkeiten und
Kompetenzen zu bündeln um eine wirksame
Bekämpfung von Finanzkriminalität zu
eine stärkere Koordinierung und
Steuerung sicherzustellen Maßnahmen zur
Geldwäschebekämpfung sollen damit
zukünftig mit dem Blick auf
Strafverfolgung Aufsicht und Analyse
Tätigkeit von Verdachtsmeldungen aus
einem Guss erfolgen entsprechend die in
Deutschland bestehenden Risiko und den
Feststeller nach der financial
Attraktion Task Force in ihrem aktuellen
Prüfungsbericht soll die Bekämpfung
komplexer und international Geldwäsche
in einer Behörde priorisiert werden und
damit nicht länger durch Ressourcen und
prioritisierungsfragen belastet werden
hin hierzu soll nach den Plänen des
Bundesfinanzministeriums unter dem Dach
einer neuen Bundesoberbehörde die als
dritte Säule neben den Analyseaufgaben
der Zentralstelle für
finanztransaktionsuntersuchungen und
einer bundesweiten Koordinierung der
geldwäscheaufsicht der Länder im
nichtfinanzsektor auch ein nach
derzeitigen Namensvorschlag
bundesfinanzkriminalamt mit
polizeilichen ermittlungsbefugnissen
vorgestellt werden das bundesfinanz
Kriminalamt soll sich auf internationale
und komplexe geldwäschefälle fokussieren
hierzu konsequenter den Ansatz voller
oder money verfolgen und sich dabei auch
von einem durch die Financial Action
Task Force kritisierten fort datenfokus
lösen im Ergebnis soll die
ressourcenbedingte Lücke bei den
Ermittlungen komplexer internationaler
Geldwäsche durch eine neue
spezialisierte Behörde geschlossen
werden ohne dabei Doppelstrukturen zu
schaffen
der Vorschlag des
Bundesfinanzministeriums wird derzeit
innerhalb der Bundesregierung erörtert
Herr Kollege Möglichkeit zu nachfragen
dass sie die Pressemitteilung praktisch
des Finanzministers aus vom August zu
verlesen gebracht haben wann dürfen wir
denn mit der Einrichtung tatsächlich
rechnen und die Frage die ich gestellt
habe war ja warum werden die vorhandenen
Organisationen die spezialisiert sind
auf diese Fragen nicht genutzt danke für
eine Antwort sehr gerne Frau Kollegin
die vorhandenen Strukturen sie sprechen
und beim Zoll an die View die wird ja
umgegliedert das wird auch eine neue
Stelle beim Zoll jetzt für die
finanztrans für die Sanktionen durch
eingesetzt die wird genauso dann mit
umgegliedert werden aber der Zoll in
seiner Struktur soll so behalten werden
und durch die Bündelung der
geldwäscheaufgaben ist es glaube ich
wichtig der Aufsicht über die Geldwäsche
dass wir hier eine neue Behörde schaffen
die dies auch bündeln kann damit wir da
effektiver werden das hat uns ja der
letzte Bericht gezeigt und wir sind
jetzt im Aufbau einer neuen Behörde ich
kann Ihnen versichern das wissen Sie
sicherlich auch dass das nicht von heute
auf morgen gehen wird es ist dazu jetzt
ein Steuer Arbeitskreis unter meinem
Kollegen mit einberufen worden
und die Möglichkeit der zweiten
Nachfrage danke wann können wir denn mit
damit rechnen dass diese Behörde
arbeitsfähig sein wird und wo wird sie
arbeitsfähig sein man munkelt dass es
sogar drei Standorte gibt also von einer
Zusammenfassung der Kompetenzen kann man
dann ja auch nicht mehr sprechen oder
also ich glaube im Zeitpunkt der
Digitalisierung kann man sehr wohl auch
an mehreren Standorten Kompetenzen
bündeln ich glaube da ist es nicht davon
abhängig dass man einen Standort bildet
wie gesagt wir sind gerade dabei die
Strukturen auch zu schaffen mit den
gewerse mit den dazu beteiligten
Ressorts und bitte haben Sie Verständnis
dass erst von das aufsteht wie auch
einen endgültigen Zeitplan nennen können
weil jetzt einen Zeitplan zu nennen und
dann nicht zu wissen wie die Strukturen
Aussehen hätte ich für unseriös
und wir haben noch eine Nachfrage
Kollegen Meister
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Staatssekretärin polizeiliche
Ermittlungsarbeit ist ja nach unserer
Verfassungsordnung Aufgabe der
Bundesländer sie haben eben dargestellt
dass sie den Aufbau dieser neuen Behörde
in der Regierung abstimmen wollen ist
denn auch daran gedacht sich mit den
Bundesländern die originär für
polizeiliche ermittlungsaufgaben
zuständig sind abzustimmen ja Kollege
daran ist gedacht wir werden jetzt
zuerst die Struktur als Bundesregierung
vorbereiten und werden dann gemeinsam
mit den Ländern auch diese besprechen
ist mit der Finanzministerkonferenz der
Länder auch so besprochen
vielen Dank weitere Nachfragen sehe ich
nicht dann kann der Kollege Meister
gleich stehen bleiben denn wir kommen
jetzt zur Frage Nummer drei Finanzierung
der durch die gaspreisbremse entstehen
Kosten von Staatssekretärin sie dürfen
vielen Dank die Frage des Kollegen
Meisters darf ich wie folgt beantworten
die gaspreisbremse ist Teil des
wirtschaftlichen abwehrschirms den
Bundeskanzler Scholz Bundesminister
Habeck und Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
am 29 September vorgestellt haben die
gaspreisbremse wird Haushalte und
Unternehmen finanziell spürbar entlasten
und soll sogleich Anreize auf zu
Reduktion des gasverbrauches enthalten
die expertinnenkommission Gas und Wärme
hat in ihrem Zwischenbericht am letzten
Montag Vorschläge für die Ausgestaltung
der gaspreisbremse vorgelegt diese
Vorschläge werden derzeit pro geprüft
oder werden dementsprechend mit der
Regierung abgestimmt und dabei sollen
sie finanziert werden und das ist jetzt
glaube ich der Kernpunkt durch eine neu
ausgerichteten Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds den wir am Freitag
hier durch den Bundestag bringen der mit
diesen 200 Milliarden dir aufgestützt
wird diese gaspreisbremse finanzieren
soll
sie haben die Möglichkeit zu Nachfragen
ja vielen Dank wenn ich das richtig
verstehe Frau Staatssekretärin ist ja
beabsichtigt dass die aktuelle
Heizperiode bei der gaspreisbremse keine
Berücksichtigung findet sondern erst ab
März kommenden Jahres sozusagen die
gaspreisbremse wirken soll warum
klammert denn die Bundesregierung und
der Bundesfinanzminister in ihren
Überlegungen die aktuelle Heizperiode
aus
wir haben die Vorschläge der
expertinnenkommission zur Kenntnis
genommen die am Montag veröffentlicht
wurden darin ist im übrigen weil man
davon ausgeht in dieser
Expertenkommission dass die
gaspreisbremse dass die gaspreisbremse
erst zum März wirken kann auch die
Möglichkeit der Einmalzahlung bereits
für die aktuelle Heizperiode nämlich für
den dezemberabschlag vorgesehen
und die Möglichkeit einer zweiten
Nachfrage dann würde ich gleich an
diesen Vorschlag Einmalzahlung 1
Dezember anknüpfen vor Staatssekretärin
gibt es denn für diese Abschlagszahlung
in Dezember schon einen Zeitplan für die
Gesetzgebung denn nach meinem Kalender
haben wir da gerade noch sechs Wochen
sechs kalenderwochenzeit wie ist denn
beabsichtigt innerhalb dieser sechs
Wochen das Gesetzgebungsverfahren
durchzuführen und dann noch denjenigen
die das umsetzen müssen die Gelegenheit
zu geben das Geld auch zu den Empfängern
zu transferieren
wir sind gerade dabei die Vorschläge der
Expertenkommission innerhalb der
Bundesregierung am Brandner ich habe es
verstanden innerhalb der Bundesregierung
umzusetzen dazu wird jetzt wirklich
täglich in einer Kommission auch getagt
welche Vorschläge wie umgesetzt werden
und wir werden im Laufe der nächsten
Woche schätze ich dann auch den Zeitplan
haben wie wir das den Parlament
vorschlagen können
vielen Dank gibt es weitere Nachfragen
zu dem Thema das ist nicht der Fall dann
kann der Kollege Dr Meister gleich
weiter stehen bleiben weil es kommt die
vierte Frage Information der
Bundesregierung über die
Standortentscheidung der künftigen
anti-geldwäschebehörde der EU und auch
hier hat die Staatssekretärin jetzt das
Wort vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin als
Teil der von der Europäischen Kommission
vorgelegten legislängen tiefpaketes so
umfassendbekämpfung von Geldwäsche und
Terrorismus Finanzierung soll neben der
Harmonisierung des materiellen
Rechtsrahmens zur Geldwäscheprävention
auch eine EU-Behörde für die
geldwäscheaufsicht geschaffen werden
hierbei enthält dir von der Europäischen
Kommission vorgelegte
Legislativvorschlag keine Festlegungen
auf den Standort dieser Behörde die
tschechische EU-Ratspräsidentschaft hat
angekündigt das Thema im Laufe des
zweiten Halbjahres 2022 aufzugreifen zu
wollen und nach Möglichkeit auch bis
Ende Jahr des Jahres 2022 eine
Entscheidung der Standortfrage herbeizuf
weitere Einzelheiten sind uns
gegenwärtig nicht bekannt insbesondere
auch nicht diese zur Anforderung an die
Bewerbung um den Standort sowie der
Rolle des Europäischen Parlaments bei
der Standortentscheidung die
Bundesregierung fordert in der derzeit
laufenden europäischen Verhandlung zu
diesen legislativpaket das über den
Standort der Anti geldwäschebehörde
entscheidet in einem transparenten
Verfahren das anhand objektiver
Kriterien entschieden werden soll dabei
soll vor allem sichergestellt werden
dass die amla diese Behörde zügig
aufgebaut wird und ihre Operatoren
aufsichtsaufgaben wahrnehmen kann der
Bundesregierung ist informell bekannt
geworden dass die bewerbungsabsichten
neben Deutschland möglicherweise auch
bei Österreich Italien Luxemburg
Niederlande Frankreich Spanien und
Litauen bestehen also sie sehen wir sind
einem ganzen Kreis von Kollegen und es
ist nicht auszuschließen es ist darüber
hinaus auch noch weitere Interessenten
geben wird
doch hier besteht die Möglichkeit von
nachfragen wenn sie mir die einrollen
frau Präsidentin gern inwieweit hat denn
die Bundesregierung ihre Position zur
Ansiedlung von amla mit der hessischen
Landesregierung abgestimmt
Deutschland wird sich mit dem
Finanzzentrum Frankfurt das haben sie
jetzt schon vor Ort genommen um die
Aussiedlung der Amler bewerben die
Bundesregierung bereitet dabei gemeinsam
mit dem Land Hessen und der Stadt
Frankfurt eine entsprechende formelle
Werbung vor alle Beteiligten befinden
sich im engen Austausch um die
erwarteten Bewerbungskriterien mit einer
überzeugenden Bewerbung erfüllen zu
können also erwarten oft die Kriterien
und sind aber zu dritt im Austausch um
eine gute überzeugende Bewerbung
abzugeben
danke schön
wie lange haben wir noch eine Nachfrage
dazu der Kollegin kressler
ich möchte schon darauf verweisen dass
die amla ja nur eine von mehreren
Behörden ist wir haben das
Zollkriminalamt in Deutschland den
sulfahndungsdienst wir haben die fhu als
Generaldirektion 10 generalsolldirektion
wir haben die neu gegründet Glücksspiel
Regulierungsbehörde in Halle und wir
haben den europäischen
finanzstaatsanwalt EPO alle Arbeiten sie
auf dem Thema Geldwäsche und auf das
kommt jetzt noch das
bundesfinanzkriminalamt drauf es wäre
gut von ihnen zu erfahren wie denn die
Aufgaben dieser einzelnen Behörden in
Deutschland sich dann abschichten danke
für eine Antwort
liebe Frau Kollegin wenn wir wissen wie
genau dieses
bundesfinanzkriminalamt aussieht können
wir auch über die
zuständigkeitsabgrenzungen gehen ich
glaube dass die Geldwäsche die nationale
Geldwäsche Aufsicht natürlich eine enge
Abstimmung mit einer dann vielleicht und
hoffentlich nach Deutschland konnten am
la hätte die die europäische Aufsicht
hat sie haben viele
Institutionen angesprochen die sich
natürlich mit Geldwäsche beschäftigen
wir haben das Thema dass die
geldwäscheaufsicht auch sehr zerstreut
ist und das soll eben genau dieses
bundesfinanzkriminalamt dann auch in
eine Hand bringen und wir sind gerade
bei der Konzeptionierung
vielen Dank ich sehe keine weitere Frage
zu diesem Themenkomplex dann kommen wir
zur Frage Nummer 5 des Abgeordneten
Stefan Brandtner zum Thema Bewertung der
Bundesregierung einer möglichen
Absenkung der Mehrwertsteuer auf
Lebensmittel als entlastungsmaßnahme für
Verbraucher Frau Staatssekretärin sie
dürfen vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die
Frage möchte ich wie folgt beantworten
es existiert keine Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung ob und in welchem Umfang
eine Änderung der ermäßigten
Umsatzsteuersätze initiiert werden soll
im Umsatzsteuerrecht gilt für
Lebensmittel die allgemeine Systematik
der umsatzsteuerermäßigung nach der
Nahrungsmittel grundsätzlich bereits dem
ermäßigten Mehrwertsteuersatz von 7%
unterliegen nicht ermäßigt besteuert
werden Getränke
sie dürfen zwischen Nachfragen stellen
ja das war ja nicht die Frage die Frage
war ja warum sie alles so lassen wollen
wie es ist wir haben zehn Prozent
Inflation in Deutschland wir haben 18,7%
erhöhte Nahrungsmittelpreise im
Vergleich zum
Vorjahresmonat dass wir den deutschen
Bürger die Durchschnittsfamilie mit etwa
500 € im Monat zusätzlich belasten
deshalb war ja meine Frage nicht warum
die mehrwertsteuerregelungen so sind wie
sie sind sondern warum sie die nicht
ändern wollen warum greifen sie nicht zu
dem einfachen Mittel die Mehrwertsteuer
auf Lebensmittel deutlich zu senken oder
ganz abzuschaffen was im bürokratisch an
Bürokratiekosten so gut wie gar nichts
nach sich ziehen würde wenn man das mal
vergleicht wir haben ein Wumms Paket
hatten wir ja mal zu corona-zeiten dann
haben wir Entlastungspaket 1 und 2 jetzt
in dieser Krise wir haben das Doppel
Wumms Paket was ihr uns jetzt hier
verkaufen als das tollste überhaupt
alleine beim beim ersten
Entlastungspaket vielen fast eine
Milliarde Euro Bürokratiekosten an um
das umzusetzen deshalb noch mal die
Frage warum gehen Sie nicht den
einfachen Schritt alle Bürger dadurch zu
entlasten dass sie die Mehrwertsteuer
auf Lebensmittel auf grundlegend
aufgrund Nahrungsmittel deutlich senken
oder sogar abschaffen
sie wissen genau wie ich Herr Kollege
dass die Umsatzsteuer in dem
Bruttopreisen mit enthalten ist dass es
keine Möglichkeit gibt als
Bundesregierung gezielt zu entlasten
durch eine Mehrwertsteuersenkung und aus
diesem Grund gehen wir diesen Weg auch
nicht sondern haben die
entlastungspakete eins bis drei auf den
Weg gebracht und die Möglichkeit einer
zweiten Nachfrage
sie meinen jetzt weil die Mehrwertsteuer
in den Bruttopreisen drin ist würden die
Bruttopreise sich nicht verändern wenn
Sie die Mehrwertsteuer abschaffen würden
also ich weiß nicht was für Fachkräfte
sie ein Bundesfinanzministerium
beschäftigen aber das ist also das den
Leuten draußen zu erklären oder mir zu
erklären dürfte ihnen sehr schwer fallen
aber sei es darum also dass er nun
wirklich Käse was sie da erzählt aber
wie gesagt seistum vielleicht noch mal
ganz genau Staatssekretärin wir haben
ich hatte gerade schon erwähnt 10%
Inflationsrate das gab's seit 1951 noch
nie wir haben durch die steigenden
Energiepreisen eine die
Industrialisierung also wir haben das
Horrorszenario einer stadtflation statt
Nation der Wirtschaft Inflation auf der
anderen Seite darin jeder Volkswirt wenn
er überhaupt nur daran denkt dass sowas
passieren könnte wir haben es jetzt real
wir wollen Sie
sicherstellen dass die
Handlungsmöglichkeiten des Staates
weiterhin da bleiben die wollen sich aus
dieser Abwärtsspirale jemals wieder
herauskommen
ich fange jetzt erstmal an und erkläre
Ihnen gerne noch mal die Geschichte mit
dem Bruttopreis
wir haben die Thema einer
bruttopreis-verordnung deswegen wird
können wir nicht sicherstellen dass eine
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf den
Verbrauchspreis weitergegeben wird das
diskutieren wir in diesem Parlament seit
mindestens vier Jahren glaube ich da
waren sie das eine oder andere Mal
sicherlich auch hier so dass jetzt
glaube ich auch hier in dieser
Geschichte auch wissen was ich ihnen
versucht habe zu erklären aber ich kann
es Ihnen gerne später noch mal erklären
sie wissen dass wir momentan alles dafür
tun die Wirtschaft auch zu stärken eine
mit der 200 Milliarden Euro Schirm für
die gaspreisbremse auch hier genau
einzugreifen dass wir stabilisierte Gas-
und Strompreise kriegen um hier auch für
die Wirtschaft und für die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher eine
Entlastung beizubringen und Sicherheit
beizubringen
vielen Dank gibt es
weitere
Nachfragen zu diesem Themenkomplex das
sehe ich nicht dann kann der Kollege
Brandner gleich stehen bleiben denn es
kommt die Frage 6 zum Thema Bedeutung
der Transfer und Fiskalunion für den
Bestand des Eurosystems Frau
Staatssekretärin sie haben das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die
Wirtschafts- und Währungsunion wurde auf
Dauer angelegt und als
Stabilitätsgemeinschaft in der
europäischen Verträgen verankert als
Reaktion auf die globale Finanzkrise und
die europäische Staatsschuldenkrise
haben sich die Mitgliedstaaten der
Eurozone und der EU auf verschiedene
Maßnahmen verständigt und die Resilienz
der Eurozone und der Europäischen Union
zu stärken dazu gehörten Schritte im
Bereich der Finanzmarktregulierung sowie
der einheitlichen aufsichts- und
abwechslungsmechanismus für Banken und
Ergänzungen der institutionellen
Architektur durch die Schaffung des
europäischen Stabilitätsmechanismus die
Wirtschafts- und finanzpolitische
Koordinierung inklusive des fiskalischen
Regelwerks des stabilitäts-
ökonomischen ungleichgewichtsverfahren
stärkt den Charakter der Wirtschafts-
und Währungsunion als
Stabilitätsgemeinschaft für eine solide
Haushaltsführung und Wirtschaftspolitik
im Rahmen der gewirtschaftspolitischen
Koordinierung innerhalb der Europäischen
Union wird die nationalstaatliche
Wirtschafts- und Finanzpolitik überwacht
und es werden fiskalpolitische
Empfehlungen an die EU-Mitgliedstaaten
abgegeben die Bundesregierung setzt sich
im Zuge der wirtschaftspolitischen
Koordinierung kontinuierlich für eine
solide Haushalts- und Finanzpolitik an
so Weiterentwicklung des gemeinsamen
fiskalischen regelswerks hat die
Bundesregierung ein prinzipien-papier
vorgelegt gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen Partnern wollen wir die
Weiterentwicklung der Europäischen
finanzpolitischen Vorschriften erörtern
und diesbezüglich eine Einigung erzielen
europäischen Partner erwähnt und auch
das
doppel-wummspaket 200 Milliarden Euro
tun sie ja so als wenn sie die
Bevölkerung da entlasten in Wirklichkeit
geben sie ja nur ein bisschen dass der
Bevölkerung zurück was sie vorher
weggenommen haben das muss ja auch mal
klar sein das sind ja keine Almosen die
sie von da oben herabgeben sondern sie
kassieren hunderte Milliarden ein und
geben bisschen was zurück dass das
doppelbums Paket gut immerhin haben wir
das jetzt mal das kommt überwiegend
Deutschland zugute aber sofort erhitze
ich in der Europäischen Union Kritik
wenn ich das richtig vernommen habe dass
der ein oder andere europäische
Regierungschef und Finanzminister sagt
ja es geht ja gar nicht dass ihr
deutschen Politiker euch um eure
deutsche Bevölkerung kümmert wir kriegen
ja kaum noch was ab in der Europäischen
Union von diesem Hintergrund mal die
Frage finden sie es nicht grundsätzlich
eine Unverschämtheit vorbei Rahmen sind
erstmal Trainings als Trainer erstmal
den Trainingsanzug raus Entschuldigung
bitte alle anderen die Möglichkeit eine
Nachfrage zu stellen zu dem Thema jetzt
gerade vorbei gerade noch seine Frage
stellen und dann fahren wir
handlungsgemäß in der Fragestunde
keine Beleidigungen hier an der Stelle
also vor dem Hintergrund finden sie es
nicht grundsätzlich eine Unverschämtheit
das überhaupt in die innenpolitische
Auseinandersetzung sich seitens der
einiger Regierungschef eingemischt
eingemischt wird obwohl wir mit Abstand
größter Nettozahler sind und eigentlich
schon viel mehr abgeben als es sein
müsste
Frau Staatssekretärin vielen Dank frau
Präsidentin ich glaube Herr Brandner wir
haben unterschiedliche Vorstellungen was
unverschämt ist und was nicht
unverschämt ist
um auf den Kern der Frage glaube ich
zurückzukommen der da war wie die
anderen Staaten unser Paket finanziert
haben sie wissen dass letzte Woche 3.4
Oktober der ECOFIN war der
eu-finanzministers treffen dort hat der
Bundesfinanzminister auch die Maßnahmen
den anderen Staats- und als in anderen
Finanzministern erläutert und damit war
auch dieses Thema für uns und für die
Europa Finanzminister erledigt und die
Möglichkeit einer zweiten Nachfrage ja
gerade die Erledigung interessiert mich
sehr zumal ja die europäische kommt die
EU-Kommission Ende Mai die
eu-schuldenregelung wieder außer Kraft
gesetzt hat das heißt die
Neuverschuldung der Mitgliedstaaten der
Europäischen Union galoppiert weiter
dieses Schengen diese schengen-kriterien
wurden ja von Anfang an nicht so richtig
ernst genommen also da geht's jetzt
weiter wir haben steigende Zinsen das
auch Auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaftliche Stabilität gerade
Südeuropas hat also die Frage wird da
sein wie wird sich was haben sie jetzt
schon wieder
Kollege Brandner bitte führen Sie Ihre
professionelle und Ziel haben sie ja vor
dem vor dem Hintergrund müssen wir uns
auf weitere Rettungsschirme jetzt auch
noch wieder vorbereiten also droht eine
weitere Krise zu Eurorettung
Herr Kollege Brantner was in der Kollege
Graf Lambsdorff erklären wollte war dass
sie Schengen mit Maastricht verwechselt
haben das war gehe ich jetzt von ihnen
aus ein Versprechen
schenken Sie die Grenzen würde ich
gerade aber das wissen Sie dann auch es
ist natürlich eine wichtige Geschichte
aber ich wollte ihnen ja nur vorsichtig
hier Beihilfe geben zur Erläuterung über
was wir gerade springen
alles gut Herr Brandner jetzt hat die
Finanz jetzt hat die Staatssekretärin
die Möglichkeit zu antworten und ihre
Frage war ob wir davon ausgehen dass wir
ein neues EU-Rettungspaket brauchen wenn
ich Sie richtig verstanden habe
wir gehen davon von den derzeitigen
lagen nicht aus dass es sowas momentan
gibt sondern dass die momentan
Regelungen dafür ausreichen
gibt es zu dem Themenkomplex zu dem
Thema noch Fragen aus den anderen
Fraktionen das sehe ich nicht dann
fahren wir fort mit der Frage Nummer 7
des Abgeordneten Dr Michael Kaufmann
mögliche Einführung einer Sonderabgabe
oder übergewinnsteuer für die Hersteller
von covid 19 Impfstoffen Frau
Staatssekretärin sie haben das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die Frage
darf ich wie folgt beantworten eine
Zusatzsteuer auf Gewinne und Forschungs-
und Entwicklungstätigkeit ist derzeit
oder ist nicht geplant sie würde nämlich
unsere Ansicht nach innovations- und
wachstumshemmen wirken deswegen kann ich
Ihre Frage mit Nein beantworten und Herr
Kaufmann sie haben die Möglichkeit mal
nachfragen die Frage war auch nicht auf
Forschungs- und Entwicklungskosten
beschränkt sondern es geht um die
Gewinner die erheblichen Gewinne die ich
auch noch mal den Herrn Montgomery
zitieren die unanständigen Gewinne der
Impfstoff
die
möglicherweise zu nutzen um zum Beispiel
Schäden die durch die Impfstoffe erzeugt
wurden zu begleichen darum ging es
vielleicht können Sie mir das noch
beantworten ob das möglich ist
Abgeordnete die Bundesregierung und das
Bundesfinanzministerium dass ich hier
vertreten darf kann schwierig zwischen
unanständigen und anständigen Gewinn
unterscheiden dementsprechend bleibe ich
bei der Antwort die ich Ihnen gerade
gegeben habe
und die Möglichkeit der zweiten zwischen
Nachfrage
danke
vielen Dank gibt es weitere
gibt es weitere Fragen zu den
Themenkomplex es ist nicht der Fall dann
kommen wir zur Frage Nummer 8 auch das
Abgeordneten Dr Kaufmann zum Thema
Gefahr einer Schwächung
mittelständischer Unternehmen aufgrund
der Zahlung der
inflationsausgleichsprämie Frau
Staatssekretärin sie dürfen vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin mit der Möglichkeit
einer freiwilligen zusätzlichen Zahlung
der Unternehmen ihre Beschäftigten von
bis zu 3000 Euro ohne zusätzliche
Belastungen durch Steuern und
Sozialversicherungsabgaben ermöglicht
die Bundesregierung eine wirkungsvolle
Stärkung der Einkommen von
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
federt somit Kaufkraftverluste aufgrund
der aktuellen hohen Teuerung ab davon
profitieren auch die Unternehmen diese
Einschätzung teilen sowohl die
Arbeitnehmer als auch die
Arbeitgeberseite wie in den bisherigen
Sitzungen der konzentrierten Aktion vom
14 Juli und 15 September deutlich
geworden ist
vielleicht darf ich da kurz eine
Situationsbericht aus meinem Wahlkreis
geben dort sehen sich heute kleine
mittelständische Unternehmer schon der
Situation gegenüber das Arbeiten immer
von gut verdienten Großunternehmen
abgeworben werden dieser Effekt wird
sich tendenziell verstärken sind sie
gehen sie damit mit mir einer Meinung
dass das zu einer weiteren
auseinanderspaltung des von
geringverdienenden oder oder weniger gut
verdienen Unternehmen und
gut aufgestellt
ja vielen Dank frau Präsidentin wir
haben die Situation dass wir momentan
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt sowohl einen
Fachkräftemangel haben wie natürlich
auch einen Arbeitskräftemangel und eine
schwierige Situation für das eine oder
andere Unternehmen die inflationsprämie
ist aber genau deswegen auch so
ausgestaltet dass sie gestückelt bis zum
31.12.2024 gezahlt werden kann dass auch
jeder Unternehmer die Möglichkeit hat
seinen Arbeitnehmern eine solche
inflationsprämie zusätzlich zu zahlen
Herr Kaufmann die Möglichkeit der
zweiten Zwischenfrage ist nicht der Fall
dann haben wir noch einen Kollegen aus
der AFD der eine Nachfrage hat zum Thema
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Angestellte gibt es ja nicht immer
Unternehmen sondern auch im öffentlichen
Dienst deswegen die Frage Platte die
bundesbürgerbehörde oder die
Bundesregierung für die Angestellten
immer für den Dienst bei den
Bundesbehörden auch diese Inflation
bringen
die
Bundesregierung plant momentan außerhalb
von Tarifverhandlungen keine weiteren
Zahlungen
und der Abgeordnete Brandner hat noch
eine Nachfrage
ja das interessant in die Richtung geht
meine Frage auch sie haben ja mit dem ja
mit der Ankündigung seit 3000 Euro
Sonderprämien Zahlungsmöglichkeit sag
ich mal im weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung
dafür gesorgt dass Jan Hoffnungsschimmer
entstanden ist sie haben da also fast
faktischen Vertrag zu Lasten Dritter
gemacht indem sie gesagt haben der
Arbeitgeber kann das Bezahlen jetzt
haben natürlich viele die Hoffnung dass
das Geld auch kommt die Arbeitgeber
wissen nicht wie sie es finanzieren
sollen das kam mir gerade an und sie
machen sich da jetzt als Bundesregierung
und schlanken Fuß und sagen aber für uns
gilt das nicht wie Bundesbedienstete für
Bundesbeamte soll das nicht gelten also
diese Prämie diese Hoffnung wecken wir
nur in der Privatwirtschaft aber nicht
im öffentlichen Dienst wie geht das denn
wie geht das denn zusammen
Kollege Brantner ich habe gesagt wir
planen außerhalb von Tarifverhandlungen
momentan keine weiteren Zahlungen und
damit bleibe ich auch und sie können den
Zwischensatz hoffentlich auch
interpretieren ohne dass ich Ihnen den
erklären muss
vielen Dank dann sehe ich keine weiteren
Fragen mehr zur diesem Komplex dann
kommen wir zur Frage Nummer 19 und 11
die alle drei schriftlich beantwortet
werden das für Kollegen Christian Haase
und Kollege Antje Tillmann und wir
kommen zur mündlichen Beantwortung zur
Frage Nummer 12 des Kollegen Florian
Ostner zum Thema mögliche Notwendigkeit
eines Nachtragshaushalts für das Jahr
2022 als Folge des dritten
entlastungspakets Frau Staatssekretärin
sie dürfen vielen Dank die Frage des
Kollegen Osna darf ich wie folgt
beantworten ein Nachtragshaushalt 2022
ist hierfür nicht erforderlich der
bisherige haushaltsverzug 2022 lässt die
Einschätzung zu dass die Belastungen aus
dem dritten Entlastungspaket die den
haushaltsbezug Einnahmen und
ausgabeseitig voraussichtlich mit zehn
Milliarden Euro belasten werden im
Rahmen der bestehenden Grid
Ermächtigungen aufgefangen werden können
eine Erhöhung der kreditermenge ist
hierfür nicht erforderlich
die Möglichkeit von Zwischenfragen
Nachfragen viele vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin vielen Dank für die
Beantwortung für Staatssekretärin wir
hatten gerade im Bereich des
entlastungspakets drei noch eine
hebliches Risiko nämlich die
Verhandlungsbasis mit den Ländern
insgesamt sollen sich die Länder ja
mindestens mit 18 Milliarden Euro
beteiligen können Sie dazu schon sagen
ob es einen Durchbruch gab und wann
diese erfolgen soll
sie wissen dass es eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gab die
sich damit beschäftigt haben wir haben
morgen auch die Finanzministerkonferenz
noch einmal momentan sind die gibt es
noch die Verhandlungen mit den Ländern
wir haben noch keine wirklichen
Entscheidungen dazu getroffen und die
Möglichkeit einer zweiten Nachfrage
mal vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit der
Nachfrage wenn sie am erlauben dieses
Risiko wenn das nicht aus der Welt
geschaffen wird und sich die Länder in
der Tat am Ende nicht dazu bereit
erklären würden sie die dann die
Ausgangsfrage ob nicht der
Nachtragshaushalt notwendig wäre genauso
beantworten weil dann wird es am Ende
nicht bei den 10 Milliarden seitens des
Bundes bleiben also meine konkrete
Nachfrage sind die Reserven so groß dass
letztendlich auch das Paket der Länder
mit übernommen werden könnte
Kollege ausner soweit ich weiß sind sie
ja Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss
dementsprechend wissen Sie ja auch viel
über dem Bundeshaushalt und wissen dann
auch dass diese Frage schon unter
gewissen Voraussetzungen von mir auch so
beantwortet worden ist sie wissen aber
glaube ich auch dass die Länder eine
gesamtstaatliche Verantwortung haben auf
die wir auch noch mal zudringen werden
dass sie auch dem Entlastungspaket 3 und
den Maßnahmen zustimmen Teilen der
Maßnahmen haben nächsten Freitag im
Bundesrat auch schon zugestimmt
und ich sehe keine weitere Frage mehr
aus den anderen Fraktionen dann kann
Herr osner gleich stehen bleiben denn
wir kommen zur Frage Nummer 13
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse in den
Jahren 20 22 fort folgende trotz der
Verstaatlichung des
Energiekonzerns Juniper Frau
Staatssekretärin sie dürfen vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin die Frage durfte ich
wie folgt beantworten die
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen beispielhaft für
die Folgen des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegenüber gegen der
Ukraine und die notwendigen Maßnahmen
zur Abmilderung der folgen die
Bundesregierung hat entschlossen
reagiert und umfangreiche Maßnahmen zu
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sowie zu Unternehmen zur Stützung der
Wirtschaft und zur Sicherung der
Energieversorgung beschlossen das war
auch eine der Maßnahmen dass wir hier
Juniper gerettet haben gleich
wohlschließen sich Krisenbewältigung und
Einhaltung des Regelwerks für die
Schuldenbremse nicht aus so wie wir es
gerade dargestellt haben
sie dürfen Nachfragen Hausner
frau Präsidentin dass sie mir wieder die
Nachfrage gestatten Frau
Staatssekretärin auch da bin ich wieder
beim Risiko wie bei fast der
vorangegangenen Frage insgesamt
subsumiert sich ja die uniper
Unterstützung wenn man jetzt wirklich
alles in einen Topf wirft mit
Kapitalerhöhung mit Leistungen zum
Einkauf von Gas auf insgesamt 35
Milliarden Euro und jetzt stellt sich
für mich die Frage bleibt es dabei oder
sehen Sie noch weitere Notwendigkeiten
auch jetzt was die Übernahme Fragen im
Nachgang noch anbelangt bei uniper dass
hier noch weitere Kostenrisiken
entstehen
die Kosten Risiken sehe ich momentan
nicht nichtsdestotrotz wissen wir alle
dass die Situation momentan sehr sehr
schwierig ist aufgrund dieses
energiekrieges den wir gerade führen
aber momentan sehe ich sie nicht
zweite Nachfrage noch möglich danke ganz
kurze Nachfrage wieder zur Ausgangsfrage
zurück der
Schuldenbremse die ja in der Verfassung
bei uns steht an dem in dem Sinne auch
keinen Wunschkonzert ist sie sagen sie
können nochmals bestätigen dass wir 2023
fortfolgende der Bruch der
Schuldenbremse seitens der
Bundesregierung nicht angedacht und
nicht geplant ist
Klinge aus einer vielen Dank erstmal für
die Frage noch mal zur Schuldenbremse
und auch der Aussage dass die
Schuldenbremse kein Wunschkonzert ist
sondern ein verfassungsmäßiger Auftrag
vielen Dank auch dafür sie wissen dass
wir sagen und der Haushaltsentwurf den
sie ja gerade auch beraten im die
Schuldenbremse 2023 einhält wir gehen
davon aus dass wir das auch 20 24 20 25
weiter tun werden Sie wissen aber auch
dass es Notlagen gibt mit denen man aus
der Schuldenbremse die Schuldenbremse
und nicht umgehen kann aber die
Schuldenbremse lockern kann und sie
wissen wie ich das mir momentan nicht in
der ganzen Zeit der Krisen haben die
Kristallkugel haben dass ich ihn hier
jetzt eine verbindliche Erklärung
abgeben kann wie es in den weiteren
Jahren abgeht aber ich kann Ihnen
verbindlich erklären dass der
Bundeshaushalt 2023 innerhalb der
Schuldenbremse bleibt
und es gibt eine Nachfrage ist Kollegen
Brandner
gerade den Gesamtaufwand von 35
Milliarden Euro für die Rettung von
uniper dargelegt hat mal meine Frage
Juniper hat ja unter stell das mal
jahrelang viele Jahre lang gutes Geld
verdient und diejenigen die an Juniper
beteiligt waren denke ich mir auch gut
versorgt dadurch das große Gewinne da
waren jetzt macht unipa dann irgendwann
Verlust dann machen sie die staatsstatue
aus holen 35 Milliarden Euro raus um
Juni hat zu retten wie ist denn geplant
dass der deutsche Steuerzahler der ja
von den Gewinnen vorher auch nicht
profitiert hat irgendwann mal in der
Zukunft diese 35 Milliarden vielleicht
auch dann Gewinnanteile bin mal wieder
Gewinne gemacht werden wieder bekommt
sie haben sie gerade gesagt momentan
sind wir dran beteiligt wenn der Gewinne
machen würde würden die Gewinne in den
Bundeshaushalt einführen
es gibt nur die Möglichkeit einer
Nachfrage
vielen Dank ich sehe keine weitere
Nachfrage mehr die Fragen 14 der
Abgeordneten Kollegin Julia Klöckner und
die Frage 15 der Kollege des Kollegen
Christian Görke werden schriftlich
beantwortet und wir kommen zur Frage
Nummer 16 der Abgeordneten Bayram
zum Thema Abgabe der
grundsteuererklärung und mögliche
Fristverlängerung Frau Staatssekretärin
sie haben das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die Abgabe
und das Verfahren zur
grundsteuererklärung liegen bei den
Ländern wir sind mit dem Ländern im
regelmäßigen Austausch morgen ist
Finanzministerkonferenz da ist das
wieder ein Thema aber es ist nicht
Aufgabe der Bundesregierung eine
Verlängerung der
abgabeerklärung für die Grundsteuer zu
initiieren
sie haben die Möglichkeit von nachfragen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin es gab eine
Äußerung des Bundesfinanzministers dazu
deswegen würde ich schon gerne wissen ob
es in Ihrem Haus eine Meinung dazu gibt
oder ob sie sich darauf vorbereiten
wie die Menschen unterstützt werden
können die diese vielleicht nicht
fristgerecht abgeben können
die Nachfrage darf ich wie folgt
beantworten ja der Bundesfinanzminister
hat gesagt er geht auf die Länder zu
wegen einer eventuellen
Fristverlängerung bleibt aber bei meiner
ersten Aufgabe ist Aufgabe der Länder
die Bundesregierung hat neben dem dass
sie für die Verwaltungsverfahren der
Grundsteuer nicht zuständig der
grundsteuererklärung nicht zuständig ist
einen Grundsteuer lotsenprogrammiert der
genau dabei vielen vielen Fällen die
nach dem bundessteuermodell sind helfen
kann und auch sehr hilfreich in Anspruch
genommen wird
vielen Dank meine weitere Frage wäre
gibt es denn seitens des
Bundesfinanzministeriums weitere
Angebote um Unterstützung den Ländern zu
geben das ist ja ein übergreifendes
Thema und wenn ja wie sehen die aus
es gibt keine Unterstützungsmaßnahmen
gegenüber den Ländern weil ich jetzt
auch mir jegliche Fantasie fehlt wie die
aussehen sollte weil die
grundsteuererklärung müssen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger abgeben wir
sprechen nicht darüber ob die Länder
momentan die grundsteuererklärungen
verarbeiten können deswegen wüsste ich
jetzt auch nicht wie eine Unterstützung
der Länder aussehen könnte Frau Kollegin
so ich grüße Sie herzlich wie kann ich
erschrecken hier Protokollantin fragen
sich schon ob jemand vom Stuhl gefallen
ist nein wir haben nur gewechselt
deswegen so viel Stille gerade und ich
rufe auf den Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesministeriums des inneren und für
Heimat zur Beantwortung steht bereit die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin Rita
schwarze du Sutter
und wir kommen zunächst zu der Frage des
Abgeordneten pterka hier geht es um
eingeleitete Maßnahmen zum
schutzkritischer Infrastruktur seit
Beginn der 20 Wahlperiode vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter Kollege
ich beantworte Ihre Frage wie folgt seit
Beginn der 20 Wahlperiode hat die
Bundesregierung unter anderem folgende
Maßnahme zu Erhöhung des Schutz des
kritischer Infrastrukturen getroffen
erstens die Bundesregierung hat am 13
juli 2022 die deutsche Strategie zur
Stärkung der Resilienz gegenüber
Katastrophen kurz resilienzstrategie
beschlossen die resslehrgangsstrategie
ist eine Strategie der Bundesregierung
mit dem Ziel Menschen und ihre
Existenzgrundlagen besser zu schützen
sowie die widerstands- und
Anpassungsfähigkeit des Gemeinwesens
gegenüber Katastrophen zu stärken ein
wesentlicher Fokus der Strategie ist
auch die Stärkung der Resilienz
kritischer Infrastrukturen zweit die
Bundesregierung hat sich in der
Beratungen der EU-Richtlinie über die
Resilienz kritischer Inneneinrichtungen
sehr Richtlinien und die EU-Richtlinie
über Maßnahmen für ein hohes gemeinsames
cybersicherheitsniveau in der Union NIS
zwei Richtlinie erfolgreich mit den
deutschen Verhandlungspositionen
eingebrachten entscheidend auf die
Erreichung von kompromissexen hingewirkt
die Arbeiten zu den Umsetzungsarbeiten
haben bereits begonnen drittens auf
Grundlage des Wassers
sicherstellungsgesetzes wurden in
genannten in der genannten Wahlperiode
Maßnahmen zur Stärkung der Resilienz im
kritisektor Wasser in Höhe von 15
Millionen Euro umgesetzt unter anderem
Härtung der Wasserinfrastruktur oder
Notstromversorgung in der
Wasserversorgung viertens es findet
kontinuierlich und in benannten Zeitraum
ach laut auch lagebedingt verstärkt ein
ressort-ebenenübergreifende
Informationsaustausch zwischen Behörden
zu drittes Themen statt sowie über die
unterschiedlichen arbeitsformate des USP
kritis auch mit den Betreibern
die vom Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz
und Katastrophenhilfe veröffentlichen
Leitfäden und Empfehlungen zum Schutz
von kritis sektorübergreift sowie
sektorspezifisch werden stetig
weiterentwickelt und aktualisiert der
schutzkritischer Infrastrukturen hat
hohe Priorität für die Bundesregierung
weshalb kontinuierlich Handlungsbedarfe
geprüft werden und entsprechend
Maßnahmen getroffen werden
eine Nachfrage bitte sehr
ja vielen Dank für die Ausführungen die
auf den ersten Blick halbwegs beruhigend
wirken könnten wir haben aber auch eine
ganz andere Entwicklung erlebt am
Samstag die Anschläge auf die
Infrastruktur der Bahn die ja auch von
Fachleuten so beschrieben wurden dass
hier quasi Insider am Werk gewesen sein
müssen dass es also nicht
gelegenheitsanschlag auf irgendeinen
Schaltkasten nur war gibt es da jetzt
ganz konkrete
Maßnahmen über die bisherigen
Ausführungen hinaus bitte zum Beispiel
Bildung einer Taskforce etc weil der
Staat scheint ja ziemlich überrumpelt
worden zu sein am Samstag
da der Betreiber
tatsächlich auch das eines bundeseigenen
Unternehmens betrifft wird im
Verkehrsministerium auch entsprechende
Maßnahmen getroffen außerdem tauscht
sich die Bundespolizei mit der DB-AG
über weitere Maßnahmen aus
noch eine zweite Nachfrage von ihnen ja
dann noch zum zum bahnanschlag
sicherheitsexperten haben wiederholt
darauf hingewiesen dass die
Vorgehensweise auf Linksextremismus
hindeutet haben sie da irgendwelche
Erkenntnisse es gab ja auch eine
wichtige Demo am Samstag der Zufall ist
schon sehr merkwürdig und wie gesagt
mehrere Fachleute haben eben das ganze
Vorgehen als eindeutig
linksextremistisch
bewertet haben sie da Erkenntnisse die
wir noch nicht kennen diese Fachleute
die dieses als eindeutig
linksextremistisch bewertet haben die
kenne ich nicht und da liegen auch keine
Erkenntnisse vor es liegt auch kein
Bekennerschreiben vor insoweit gibt es
bisher keine keine Feststellung wer
tatsächlich Täter ist und
es kann auch ein zum Beispiel
links rechts oder auch fremde Stärken
sein
jetzt zwei Beispiele dafür aufgezeigt wo
der Schutz der kritischen Infrastruktur
nicht funktioniert hat das wird einmal
die doch sehr wichtigen Pipelines in der
Ostsee und zum anderen jetzt ja der Zug
Funk der offenbar durch zwei geschälten
gezielte Schnitte in Kabel in ganz
Norddeutschland zufällig am Tag der
afd-demonstration dazu führte dass gar
kein Zug mehr vor den ganzen
Norddeutschland meine Frage nochmal ich
Vergangenheit gerichtet wie waren denn
konkret die Sicherungsmaßnahmen
betreffend die Pipeline wie war denn die
Pipeline geschützt als kritische
Infrastruktur und wie waren denn diese
Kabel die da durchgeschnitten wurden die
in Zukunft betreffen wie waren die denn
geschützt sehr geehrter Brandner sie
wissen sicherlich dass der Schutz auch
von den Infrastrukturen von den
Betreibern zu leisten ist und insofern
ist es der Betreiber von Nordstemmen 1
und Nord Stream 2 und bei der Bahn ist
es natürlich bei den Bahnen die DB AG
und und hier ist der Schutz auch die
Gefahrenabwehr liegt bei der
Bundespolizei und insofern ja zusammen
Recht das sind 35.000 Kilometer
Bahnstrecke und entsprechend wird man
sich jetzt noch mal zusammensetzen und
über verstärkte Maßnahmen
diskutieren wie dieser Schutz verbessert
werden kann
Herr Kraft
vielen Dank Frau Staatssekretärin sie
haben ja am Anfang den ganzen Strauß am
Maßnahmen vorgelesen den die
Bundesregierung hier verfolgt in der 20
Legislatur um diese Anschläge für die
die oder für die Sicherheit für die die
Betreiber verantwortlich sind
sicherzustellen nun sind diese
Vorkommnisse passiert darüber hinaus hat
es auch ja dutzendfach Vorfälle gegeben
bei dem wichtige
Standorte der Infrastruktur der
Energieinfrastruktur wie
Braunkohlekraftwerke wie Gas
Verdichterstation von sogenannten
Aktivisten Behinderten stillgelegt
worden ist würden Sie also im Rahmen all
dieser Maßnahmen den Pipeline Anschlägen
den Anschlag auf die Deutsche Bahn den
Eingriffen in die Energieinfrastruktur
durch sogenannte Aktivisten würden Sie
sagen dass ihre Maßnahmenpaket
ausreichend ist weil es bisher diese
Dinge nicht hat verhindern können
also ich muss darauf hinweisen dass wie
gesagt als erstes die Betreiber
zuständig sind für den Schutz und wenn
eine konkrete bedrohungsvorlage darlegt
auch die Polizei der Länder entsprechend
tätig wird und wie weit wir den Schutz
der kritischen Infrastrukturen über das
hinaus wir und wir sprechen natürlich
auch mit den Unternehmen wir haben ein
Initiative wirtschaftsschutz und da geht
es darum insbesondere nach dem 24
februar die Resilienz und die
Widerstandskraft entsprechend zu erhöhen
so vielen Dank damit beende ich die
Fragestunde
und rufe auf den Zusatzpunkt aktuelle
Stunde
die Fraktionen der SPD von Bündnis 90
die Grünen und FDP haben eine Aktuelle
Stunde verlangt zu dem Thema Ergebnisse
der unabhängigen Kommission Erdgas und
Wärme der Bundesregierung sicher durch
den Winter
danke
alle Platzwechsel
erledigt dann
gebe ich das Wort an Julia verlinken für
Bündnis 90 Sekunden
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen
wir haben im Augenblick zwei
Herausforderungen im Gasmarkt das eine
sind die deutlich gestiegenen Preise und
das andere ist dass uns in Europa
weniger Gas zur Verfügung steht als in
den letzten Jahren
zum ersten dazu hat die
expertinnenkommission bis Montag früh um
sechs es ging fast schon die Sonne auf
an einem Zwischenbericht gearbeitet
herzlichen Dank an dieser Stelle an alle
die daran mitgewirkt haben auch an den
vielen Mitarbeiterinnen die mit dabei
waren bis zum Ende und auch im
Hintergrund sehr viel dafür geleistet
haben
und Tatsache ist es werden in diesen
Zwischenbericht Instrumente für alle
gaskundinnen für alle fernwärmekundinnen
vorgeschlagen das heißt sowohl die
privaten Haushalte als auch die
Bäckereien als auch die Sportstätten die
Krankenhäuser und natürlich auch für die
Industrie gibt es in diesem Bericht
Vorschläge was die Politik jetzt tun
kann um groß zu entlasten und die
Entlastung sind vor allem für diejenigen
wichtig die gerade in eine besonders
schwierige Situation zu geraten drohen
und auch hierfür sind konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht worden sind diese
Vorschläge werden jetzt von der
Bundesregierung geprüft und daran sind
zahlreiche Ministerien beteiligt denn
selbstverständlich sind hier auch viele
Ressourcen die dafür jetzt
umsetzungsprüfungen übernehmen müssen ob
Gesetze möglicherweise genau so oder ein
bisschen anders realisiert werden können
und ich glaube es ist allen allen in den
Ministerien aber natürlich auch uns hier
im Bundestag bewusst es braucht eine
schnelle Unterstützung und deswegen
werden wir das auch so schnell ist
irgendwie auf den Weg bringen
und um Missverständnisse zu vermeiden
allein dass derzeit teure Gas zu
subventionieren das wird nicht
ausreichen in der aktuellen schwierigen
Situation denn die begrenzte Menge wird
dadurch nicht mehr dass man es
subventioniert im Gegenteil wenn alle
genau dieselbe Menge verbrauchen wie in
der Vergangenheit dann könnte es ein
Problem geben denn leider sind
zahlreiche Lebens- und
Wirtschaftsbereiche bei uns noch
abhängig vom Erdgas viel zu viele
Gebäude werden mit gasbeheizt der
Umstieg auf erneuerbare Wärme auf
Energieeffizienz ist in den letzten
Jahren viel zu langsam vorangegangen und
zahlreiche Menschen arbeiten mit
Hochdruck daran mehr Wärmepumpen
einzubauen Windräder zu planen
Solaranlagen auf die Dächer zu bringen
und all das ist ein wichtiger Beitrag
dafür ganz herzlichen Dank aber man kann
eben auch nicht alles von heute auf
morgen herbeizaubern
alle Speicher in Deutschland sind gut
gefüllt auch dafür vielen Dank an
diejenigen die daran beteiligt waren
Wirtschaft und Regierung alle die daran
mitgearbeitet haben aber gefüllte
Speicher allein reicht nicht um sich
entspannt zurückzulehnen denn hier
kälter der Winter wird je mehr geheizt
wird hier desto weniger Energie ist dann
möglicherweise für die Industrie zur
Verfügung in den nächsten Monaten und
auch das betrifft dann auch die Menschen
die dort arbeiten ich hoffe dass die
Bundesnetzagentur als lastverteiler
nicht entscheiden wird oder entscheiden
muss Gas zu rationieren sodass große
Unternehmen in einer gasmangelage ihre
Produktion oder ein Teil davon
Herunterfahren müssen deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir kommunizieren dass die
Lage ernst ist dass alle einen Beitrag
leisten können und auch sollten um Wärme
einzusparen und die Kommission will
genau deswegen im Abschlussbericht Ende
Oktober ausführlich dazu Empfehlungen
abgeben das zum Thema Energieeffizienz
und Energie sparen jetzt politisch
sinnvoll ist und dazu gehören auch
Investitionen denn Investitionen in die
Transformation in der Industrie in den
Wasserstoff hochlaufen in
energiesparende Technologien in
Gebäudesanierung in die erneuerbaren
Energien das ist die beste Versicherung
gegen hohe Energiepreise
und klar ist
die Investitionen sind wichtig und es
gibt auch kleine Dinge die jetzt
parallel von vielen gemacht werden
können denn kleine Dinge die in der
Summe einen riesigen Unterschied machen
können
ein weiteres wichtiges Argument ist wenn
wir den Verbrauch reduzieren dann hat
das auch preisdämpfende Wirkung und das
hilft dann auch allen uns gemeinsam
wieder bei dieser Herausforderung bei
der Entlastung und ich finde eine Sache
die braucht auch noch mehr
Aufmerksamkeit wir reden viel über
Verfügbarkeit des Gases die Preise vom
Erdgas und so weiter und das ist auch
wichtig dass wir hier auch den Menschen
Sicherheit geben und sagen keiner wird
allein gelassen wir unterstützen alle
bleiben aber beim Thema es geht jetzt in
der Aktuellen Stunde hier im Bundestag
genau darum nämlich um die Vorschläge
der Gaspreis Kommission es steht gerade
am Rednerpult Julia verlinken für die
Grünen weiterhin in einer Sicht täglich
verschärfen den Klimakrise und auch
deswegen ist es sinnvoll wenn wir hier
mit der Transformation schnell
voranschreiten vielen Dank
ja Julia verlinken hatte fünf Minuten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Kollegin
Dr Verlinden es muss schnell gehandelt
werden
keiner wird alleine gelassen kein Bürger
kein Betrieb das waren in etwa die Worte
von Bundeskanzler Olaf scholzers am 22
juli seine Pressekonferenz gegeben hat
und seine Botschaft gegeben hat Jul
never walk alone
das ist richtig zitiert und es ist auch
richtig zitiert wenn ich dann dazu sage
und dann hat er aber die gasumlage dort
vorgeschlagen die die Preise verteuert
hätte hätte Olaf Scholz im 22 juli des
klare Signal gegeben wir lassen keinen
allein und deshalb kommt eine
Preisbremse und dafür setzen wir eine
Kommission ein dann würde die
gaspreisbremse uns in diesem Winter
helfen können und nicht aus dem März
oder April
und das ist unser Punkt wir haben
Respekt von der Arbeit der Kommission
und wir werden sehr konstruktiv diese
Vorschläge bearbeiten und werden darauf
drängen dass die gaspreisbremse schnell
unbürokratisch und ein Gesamtkonzept
umgesetzt wird aber fest steht damit
auch die Kommission ist zum Ergebnis
gehören man braucht ein Vorlauf von vier
Monaten und deshalb werden wir die
gaspreisbremse in diesem Winter nicht
haben und deshalb schlägt sie ja für den
Winter für die Zeit davor eine Brücke
vor mit einer Einmalzahlung die je
länger man sich damit beschäftigt mehr
Fragen aufwirft als beantwortet der soll
Bezug genommen werden auf den September
im Sept auf die Abschläge dort da sind
aber viele der Preiserhöhung noch gar
nicht angekommen gewesen kann eine
Einmalzahlung für den September
tatsächlich durch die Zeit mindestens
September Oktober November Dezember
Januar Februar März vielleicht kommt die
Preisbremse ja erst im April das ist ein
sehr sportlicher Plan hört man aus der
Kommission bleibt die Geldzahlung
eigentlich gleich hoch egal ob die
Bremse im März kommt oder im April da
sind viele Fragen unbeantwortet die
Regierung hat durch ihr verspätetes
handeln die Kommission in diese von ihr
auch selbst sogenannte und zumutbare
Situation gebracht
wir fordern das ein Gesamtkonzept gibt
die gaspreisbremse ist das eine wir
erwarten das jetzt auch Vorschläge macht
werden für die strompreisbremse das ist
gemeinsam umgesetzt wird wir merken das
keine Schieflage gibt zwischen den
Menschen die mit Gas heizen die Strom
nutzen und denen die noch mit Öl heizen
oder die mit Öl heizen und die auf
Pellet Pellets gesetzt haben und wir
brauchen trotz Bremsen bei Gas und bei
Strom brauchen wir bessere Unterstützung
für Normalverdiener das was
vorgeschlagen wird bedeutet ja dass
trotzdem sich die Gasrechnung im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr mehr als
verdoppeln wird
das können Menschen mit einem geringen
Einkommen nicht tragen und da ist es
richtig dass beim Wohngeld etwas gemacht
wird diese Menschen brauchen das aber es
gibt Menschen die bekommen kein Wohngeld
auch nach ihre Form kein Wohngeld aber
haben trotzdem ein so geringes Einkommen
dass sie eine
Preissteigerung die mehr als eine
Verdoppelung ist nicht werden tragen
können deshalb muss diese Bremse ergänzt
werden durch bessere Hilfen für
Normalverdiener darauf werden wir in den
Beratungen drängen
und wir halten es für falsch was die
Bundesregierung angekündigt hat die
Bundesregierung hat angekündigt dass
energiekostendämpfungsprogramms heute
morgen im energieausschuss angekündigt
dann wird zum Jahresende eingestellt
nach allem was wir kennen haben wir
nicht die Erwartung dass allen Betrieben
die jetzt in Existenz nutzen sind denn
jetzt geholfen werden muss die jetzt die
Preisexplosion haben dass denen durch
das was kommen könnte im März oder April
dass das diese Fragen beantwortet wir
setzen auf die Zusage von Robert Habeck
er hat angekündigt das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm wird so geändert das
ist ein leichteren Zugang gibt dass auch
Bäckereien dass der Mittelstand dass der
Handwerk daraus Unterstützung bekommen
kann dann nehmen wir den Minister und
wir nehmen die Bundesregierung beim Wort
diese Fragen werden nicht beantwortet
durch eine Preisbremse die vielleicht im
März oder April kommt
und bei den Pellets da haben Menschen in
Pellets investiert mit Ermunterung der
Politik mit Zuschüssen der KfW und die
rechnen es uns vor ich kenne die Zahlen
von einer Bäckerei die haben
Preissteigerungen die mehr als eine
Verdopplung sind die eine Verdreifachung
bedeuten die diese Betriebe in eine
existenzbedrohende Situation bringt da
ist bisher die Antwort der
Bundesregierung für die machen wir nicht
dabei kann es nicht bleiben da droht
eine Schieflage und deshalb trinken wir
auf ein Gesamtkonzept und zu diesem
Gesamtkonzept muss auch dazu gehören
dass es Angebot erweitert wird und
deshalb fordern wir Sie auf Beenden sie
ihren Streit in der Koalition treffen
sie es endlich eine Entscheidung die das
umsetzt was ihre eigenen Experten
fördern ein dringender Rat der Experten
der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber nutzen Sie
jetzt endlich alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung Biomasse Deckel ist
abgeräumt bei der Kohle muss es jetzt
schneller vorangehen und bei der
Kernenergie brauchen wir eine klare
Entscheidung dass das was möglich ist
nicht für diesen Winter für die Krise
jetzt gemacht wird ihr Streit belastet
das Vertrauen in die Handlungsfähigkeit
des Staates deshalb brauchen wir da ist
eine Entscheidung vielen Dank
fordert hier Andreas Jung für die
cdu/csu-fraktion er ist der Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie oder hören wir
mal was die Ampel bzw einer der
ampelkoalitionäre für die SPD in dem
Fall zu sagen hat Matthias Mörsch der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD lieber Andreas Jung ich finde
das vollkommen in Ordnung dass die
Opposition natürlich Fragen stellt
Kritik äußert aber gerade die
cdu/csu-fraktion sollte sehr vorsichtig
sein wenn man hier von den Lösungen
spricht im März haben sie hier an dieser
Stelle gefordert mit ihrem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden mit ihrem
Parteivorsitzenden das von der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein
einseitiges Gaseinbau gegenüber Russland
ausgesprochen werden soll wir würden
jetzt nicht mehr über Bremsen reden
sondern wir hätten Versorgungsprobleme
die ins Botschafter ins existenzielle
gehen würden
und deswegen muss man vorsichtig sein
wenn man hier Kritik äußert aber ich
finde es hervorragend dass sie jetzt
hier sagen sie wollen sich konstruktiv
an diesen Vorschlägen beteiligen und ich
will das im Namen der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion sagen unser Dank
gilt den Expertinnen und Experten die
aus unserer Sicht eine sehr sehr gute
Grundlage für unsere weitergehende
Beratung aufgestellt haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es ist immer so wenn eine Lösung
schnell wirken soll dann wird man in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland bei 80
Millionen Menschen immer Fälle Findern
finden wo man sagen was ist nicht
gerecht aber das erste was uns jetzt
wichtig ist ist den Menschen Sicherheit
zu geben und das steht im Vordergrund
und dass wir in der Industrie aufgrund
der Strukturen einer einfachere
Möglichkeit ab 1.1.23 diese Bremse
wirken lassen und dann vom ersten
dritten bis zum mindestens ersten
vierten 24 allen die hier in Deutschland
einen Anschluss haben diese Sicherheit
geben dieser Eingriff ins System war der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion ganz wichtig und
wir sind froh dass die
Expertenkommission diese Ansatz mit
übernommen hat
aber es ist ebenso richtig und Herr
junge ich gebe Ihnen ausdrücklich recht
wir müssen gucken was wir dazwischen
machen und das ist der Winter und
deswegen ist es aus meiner Sicht ein
Ansatz dass die Kommission sagt wir
wollen im Dezember an den
Abschlagszahlungen ansetzen und der
Staat soll diese übernehmen aber es
stellen sich weitere Fragen zum Beispiel
was ist mit Januar und Februar ist es
eigentlich gerechtfertigt das vor dem
Hintergrund der dann klar
gesetzgeberisch festgelegten Bremsen
überhaupt noch siebenfache achtfache
Abschläge von den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern verlangt werden können seitens
der Versorger auch das müssen wir jetzt
im weiteren beratungsablauf klären
und ich halte es genauso für
gerechtfertigt dass man überlegt bedarf
es weitere flankierender Maßnahmen
zwischen Dezember und März 2023 auch dem
werden wir uns stellen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und genauso ist es aus
unserer Sicht natürlich ein großes
Thema
Augen schnell wirkende Maßnahmen greifen
lassen wollen die Frage stellen wie ist
das eigentlich mit dem mit der
Gerechtigkeit hinter dem Anschluss wir
haben das große Problem dass die
versorge augenblicklich das nicht wissen
sie wissen nicht ob es ein
Einfamilienhaus ist ein Mehrfamilienhaus
eine Villa jemand der da drin wohnt zu
fünft zu zweit Reich Arm das ist diesen
Versorgern nicht bekannt und deswegen
finden wir es richtig dass die
Kommission auch auf diesen
gerechtigkeitsaspekt einer Antwort
findet indem sie sagen die Besteuerung
dessen was dort gezahlt wird ab einem
gewissen Steuersatz wäre eine
Möglichkeit auch darüber müssen wir
jetzt beraten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich sage aber auch es kann weitergehen
wenn wir von März bis April 24
mehrere Monate fast über ein Jahr diese
Bremse wirken lassen kann man auch
überlegen wenn weitere Daten vorhanden
sind ob in dieser Bremse in dieser
Bremse eine Obergrenze eingeführt wird
so dass es bei bestimmten
Einkommensklassen gar nicht mehr zu
einer Forderung bzw Förderung kommt auch
darüber werden wir reden müssen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja es ist auch zu Recht angesprochen
worden wenn auch siebenfache achtfache
Steigerungen die Ausnahme sind aber die
die auf Öl gesetzt haben die die auf
Pellets gesetzt haben sollen auch nicht
alleine gelassen werden und deswegen
werden wir im parlamentarischen
Verfahren auch diese Gruppe in den Fokus
nehmen und hier Härten auch abfedern
auch dazu hat die Kommission Vorschläge
gemacht über härtefallfonds und weiteren
Einrichtungen die wir als Grundlage
sehen um auch diese Gruppe tatsächlich
in Sicherheit zu bringen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das was die
Kommission vorgeschlagen hat ist aus
unserer Sicht ein richtiger Schritt den
Zusammenhalt in dieser schwierigen Zeit
zu organisieren vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
aber wenn man Matthias Mirsch zugehört
hat hier dann gibt es auch noch einige
offene Fragen die zu beantworten sind
die Bundesregierung hat angekündigt eine
gaspreisbremse so rasch wie möglich
umzusetzen aber dann braucht es ja eben
noch das parlamentarische Verfahren und
viele Fragen die da noch geklärt werden
müssen
[Applaus]
ja während der Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen bevor ich loslege ein kurzer
Realitätscheck wieder mal heute letzte
verfügbare Daten des fraunhofinstitutes
Wind liefert eineinhalb Gigawatt
kennenlänge 4 und sie verbrennen gerade
wieder für 9 Gigawatt Gas zur
Stromerzeugung das an die Kollegen die
meinen dass die Erneuerbaren die Lösung
der Energiekrise wären die erste
Empfehlung der Expertenkommission liegt
also vor und wie zu erwarten Land die
Regierung mit massiven Einsatz von
Steuergeldern die Probleme zu lösen die
es ohne sie natürlich nicht gäbe bis zu
200 Milliarden sollen erst aufgewendet
werden um Gas und Fernwärme wieder in
den Bereich des bezahlbaren zu bringen
und die Unternehmen sowie die Bürger zu
entlasten ob diese Summe ausreichen wird
um die Serie des energiepolitischen
Versagens der Regierung zu begleichen
ist dabei vollkommen offen
das gilt für diese Maßnahmen ist auch
gar nicht vorhanden und es wird über
weitere Schulden refinanziert ganz egal
welche Umschreibung dafür auch gewählt
werden wird der Schattenhaushalt im
betrügerischer Absicht auch gern
Sondervermögen genannt von nun 360
Milliarden Euro wird bei größer sein als
diese Summe im bundeshaushaltsplan und
das schlimmste dabei ist sie verbrennen
dieses Geld der Bürger völlig Ziel und
orientierungslos sie geben Milliarden
von eurer aus für Instrumente von denen
sie nicht wissen ob sie funktionieren
Prinzip Hoffnung und blinder teurer
Aktionismus der wieder einmal nur die
Symptome mildern soll anstatt an die
Wurzeln des Problems zu gehen und diese
Wurzel heißt ihre Energiewende ist
krachend gescheitert
über 500 Milliarden Euro mussten sich
die Stromverbraucher für Wind und
photovoltaiksubventionen aus den Taschen
ziehen lassen deren energiebeitrag im
kommenden Winter irgendwo zwischen
vernachlässigbar und unzuverlässig
schwanken wird und als auch diese zylose
Verschwendung von Geld für das Millionen
Bürger hart arbeiten müssen noch nicht
ausreicht verspotten sie die
unermüdlichen Steuerzahler dieses Landes
noch mit hochnäsigen Ratschlägen zu
Waschlappen Pullovern und wie man sich
Wasser sparend in der Dusche erleichtert
nicht nur dass sie die Bürger berauben
sie machen sich über die Bürger auch
noch lustig
aber kommen wir zu dem wenigen was wir
von ihrem Programm wissen den offiziell
ist eigentlich noch gar nichts die
Gasrechnung des Dezembers soll
übernommen werden und ab dem Frühjahr
irgendwann wenn die Heizperiode vorbei
ist wollen sie Teile des Gaspreises für
private und ab Januar für die Industrie
Deckel soweit so wenig ihr Vorhaben die
Rechnung für Dezember zu übernehmen
zeugt aber schon von ihrem mangeln
Verständnis der Sachlage während die
Gasverbraucher und Fernwärme Nutzer
einmalig und völlig unzureichend einen
Teil ihrer kostenersetzt bekommen den
Nutzer von Öl und Pelletheizungen
komplett leer aus es wurde angesprochen
und dabei sind auch in diesem Bereichen
die Brennstoffkosten stark gestiegen Öl
hat sich verdoppelt und Pellets haben
sich verdreifacht aber was ist jetzt
eigentlich mit den von ihnen viel
angepriesenen Wärmepumpen auch Strom ist
extrem teuer geworden und jetzt kommen
wir zu einer Perversität ihres
Vorschlages denn Strom wird signifikant
aus Gas erzeugt das heißt der
gasverstromer kann seine
dezemberrechnung bei Minister Lindner
einreichen aber der so subventile Strom
wird im vollen Umfang an die Stromkunden
weitergegeben dort wird von diesen
Subventionen nichts angekommen das ist
einfach noch Perversität das ist die
Solidarität aller Ampel
es drängt sich der Verdacht auf dass der
Wirtschaftsminister keine große Ahnung
von den Energie- und Wärmeerzeugung
dieser Nation hat und dazu passt auch
die Kommission für erdgossen und Wärme
hier an dieser Stelle ein Zitat des
Präsidenten von Haus und Grund Zitat die
Vorschläge wirken als wären sie von
Leuten erarbeitet worden die noch nie
eine Heizkostenabrechnung gesehen
geschweige denn erarbeitet haben Zitate
erinnert das sagt alles aus ihre
Kommission ist die Creme de la Grimm der
bundesrepublikanischen Lebenslügen und
parteibuchwirtschaft eine absurde
Mischung aus
klima-versorger und nicht zuletzt der
Caritas diktiert diese Regierung nun die
Energiepolitik
obwohl also diese Regierung durch diese
ungenügende Maßnahmen eingesteht dass
wir eine Energiekrise haben ist sie
nicht willens durch eine Mehrproduktion
von Energie diese Krise entgegen zu
wirken und zwar aus rein ideologischen
Gründen wir haben zu wenig Energie sie
warnen bereits vor dem Winter 23 24
verzichten aber generös auf viele
Gigawatt an Leistung aus Kern und
Kohlekraftwerken ihre Energiepolitik
bewegt sich jenseits der Grenzen des
Wahnsinns um der drohnen-knappheit im
kommenden Winter zu begegnen plant diese
Regierung keinesfalls mehr Energie zu
erzeugen um die Knappheit zu bekämpfen
sondern mit Hilfe von Steuermilliarden
den energiehändlern das knappe Gut Gas
zu vergolden und den europäischen
Preiskampf endgültig eskalieren zu
lassen die Regierung kapituliert dabei
nicht nur vor der mangel-lager sondern
sie hat diese verursacht der Grund dafür
liegt in der stasehnlichkeit der
Regierung die einfach nicht akzeptieren
will sich einer Frage des Kernkraft und
kohleausstieges fundamental geirrt zu
haben
und für diesen irrationalen starren
müssen die Bürger nun Milliarden ihre
Ersparnisse Opfern kommende Generationen
Erben die Schulden dieses
regierungsversagens Unternehmen droht
das Ende am Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und die die sich das alles
dann doch nicht leisten können werden im
Winter frieren vielleicht sogar hungern
die Bürger und Unternehmen in diesem
Land haben also zuerst den Schaden durch
überborden der Energiepreise dann ist
Sport einer politischen Nomenklatur der
ist ein jeglicher Empathie mangelt und
am Ende noch die Kosten den wir immer
über die Regierung die
selbstverschuldenden Probleme mit Bergen
und Bergen von Steuergeld zuschütten
für Deutschland diese Regierung
[Applaus]
der Kollege Dr Lukas Köhler spricht
jetzt für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vielleicht zu
Beginn ein paar Grundlagen ich glaube
die gehen dir Debatte öfters mal unter
das eine ist wir wissen es gibt einen
Krieg Puddings gegen die Ukraine es gibt
aber gleichzeitig und das muss man immer
so Anfang auch einmal bedenken ein
energiekrieg Putins gegen Europa und das
ist die Grundlage dieser Probleme und
das ist das was wir lösen müssen und die
müssen wir entgegentreten ich weiß die
AFD vergisst das immer sehr gerne dass
eben Putin das Problem ist aus näherer
Beziehung oder Freundschaft aber ich
glaube das muss man damit
und Zusagen und mitdenken
ich möchte
also ich habe aufgegeben zu versuchen
der AFD zu verstehen zu geben was
passiert dass der Zug abgefahren aber
zumindest zwei Sachen Herr Kollege
wollte ich schon noch einmal mitgeben
der Vorschlag der gaskommission ist noch
nicht der Vorschlag der Bundesregierung
sondern eben der der gaskommission haben
Experten und Experten wins auch die
ganzen Versorger die exakt diese
Gasrechnung geschrieben haben und die
alle da dabei saßen einen solchen
Vorschlag vorgelegt ich bin also etwas
überrascht dass sie anscheinend haben
sie selber schon Gasrechnungen
geschrieben ich bin überrascht dass Sie
das hier einfach das zweite ist und das
ist glaube ich wichtig was dieser
Vorschlag macht ist er schaut sich
explizit den gaspreiser und die
Wärmeversorgung also Gas und Fernwärme
Strom Strompreis Bremse kommt noch die
Art und Weise wie wir mit Öl und Pellets
umgehen auch das wird von der Kommission
besprochen und weiter erarbeitet und
auch da kommen Vorschläge aber man muss
es glaube ich einmal auseinanderhalten
und ich helfe da auch gerne der
positionellen Demenz der Union ein
bisschen auf die Sprünge Herr junges
Klang eben so als ob das jetzt die
einzigen Maßnahmen werden die diese
Bundesregierung auf den Weg bringen
würde und die einzigen Maßnahmen die wir
hier im Parlament schon längst
beschlossen werden nein mitnichten ist
das der Fall wir haben 96 Milliarden
Euro jetzt schon also zusätzlich zu den
200 Milliarden in die Hand genommen um
zielgerichtet die Menschen über diesen
Winter zu bringen um den Unternehmen zu
helfen um alles dafür zu tun dass auch
die Leute nicht nur die mit keinem
Einkommen Weiterkommen sondern auch zum
Beispiel über die kalte Progression
dafür gesorgt dass die Menschen mit
mittleren Einkommen auch vor der
Inflation geschützt werden und das darf
und muss man mit nennen wenn man darüber
spricht wir haben auch dafür gesorgt um
die Kollegin Kalender zum Glück ja schon
angesprochen dafür gesorgt dass die
Speicherstände auf 92 93 Prozent
hochgehen konnten dafür haben wir
gesorgt damit wir gut über diesen Winter
kommen und das ist ein wahrlicher Erfolg
genauso sorgen wir dafür gesetzlich dass
die Kohlekraftwerke jetzt in großem Maß
rausgehen und über die Kernkraftwerke da
diskutieren wir gerade und da bin ich
mir sehr sicher dass das sehr zeitnah zu
einer Lösung kommt
die
Frage die wir uns stellen müssen bei der
Bewertung dieses Konzepts dass die
gaskommission vorschlägt und da auch
noch mal vielen Dank an diese Kommission
die das wirklich finde ich sehr sehr gut
erarbeitet hat ist wir brauchen einen
Instrument oder wir brauchen mehrere
Instrumente die drei Kriterien a müssen
Sie schnell und einfach wirken sie
müssen so schnell es geht bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern aber auch bei
den Unternehmen bei den Bäckern bei den
Mittelständlern bei den Handwerkern aber
auch in der Industrie ankommen 1 Nummer
2 ist sie müssen unbürokratisch sein sie
müssen möglichst einfach akzeptiert
werden aber vor allen Dingen müssen Sie
einfach bei den Leuten und den
Unternehmen ankommen und Nummer drei und
das ist absolut zentral sie dürfen dabei
nicht den Spar Anreiz über den Jordan
gehen lassen warum weil wenn wir nicht
mehr einsparen passieren zwei Dinge
zunächst subventionieren wir gegen die
Knappheit also gegen zu wenig Gas an das
bedeutet dann dass das Geld dass wir
staatlich in die Hand nehmen würden gar
nicht mehr bei den Menschen ankommt weil
ja der
Preis der Großhandelspreis immer teurer
werden würde und das ist ein Problem und
zweitens wenn wir nicht genug sparen
meine Damen und Herren dann haben wir
eine gasmangelage dann reden wir nicht
mehr über gaspreisbremsen dann reden wir
darüber dass die Bundesnetzagentur
zuweist wer wie viel Gas bekommt und das
ist eine Situation die wir um jeden
Preis verhindern müssen weil das ist der
wirtschaftliche Abgesang dieses Landes
und deswegen ist der sparanreiz und der
ist in diesem Vorschlag drin sehr sehr
wichtig
jetzt kann man sich fragen warum
schafft die gaskommission diese
Rahmenbedingungen und ja das tut sie sie
sorgt dafür dass wir mit den 80 Prozent
in den Haushalten und den 70% bei den
Industrieunternehmen sparen reizen
lassen sie sorgt dafür dass insbesondere
die Industrie die einen größeren Teil
Schuld hat jetzt schon an Spar einen
Einsparung aber auch in Zukunft
Schultern wird das Gas dass sie auch mit
staatlicher Unterstützung bekommt weiter
handeln kann so dass da der sparanreiz
ganz klar bestehen bleibt und deswegen
ist das ein guter Vorschlag es ist eine
gute Idee so vorzugehen was aber fehlt
sind die drei wesentlichen Punkte das
zum einen das was wir jetzt diskutieren
müssen über wie sieht eine Zukunft aus
in der der lng-preis in Deutschland die
Strom- und Gaskosten setzen und das ist
die Zukunft in drei vier fünf Jahren da
müssen wir heute darüber nachdenken wie
das aussehen wird damit wir vorbereitet
sind aber das Gute ist da sprechen wir
sowohl mit dem Ministerium als auch in
den Fraktion das zweite ist dass wir
natürlich jetzt über Strom nachdenken
müssen und da kommt analog zu diesem
Vorschlag sehr bald der Vorschlag aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium damit ich mir
sicher und der letzte Punkt ist der
allerletzte Punkt ist die Frage wie wir
mit den anderen Heizkosten umgehen und
auch die werden wir senken ich bin mir
sicher dass ein sehr guter Vorschlag
vielen herzlichen Dank
ja und du kannst Köhler hat es auch
gleich zu Beginn seiner Rede gesagt das
sind Empfehlungen der Expertenkommission
das ist noch kein Gesetz
also die konkrete Umsetzung da muss man
dann normal schauen wie das genau
aussieht Dietmar Bartsch ist für die
Linke der fraktionsvorsitze Aktuelle
Stunde sondern wirklich eine
Regierungserklärung zu diesem Problem
gewünscht das wäre sinnvoll gewesen wir
alle wissen doch dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und die Betriebe in unserem
Land aufgrund der explodierenden Preise
mit dem Rücken zur Wand stehen das ist
uns allen hier bekannt und immer mehr
Menschen fragen sich wie sollen sie denn
diese Krise stemmen und ehrlich gesagt
Herr Köhler es ist nicht die einzige
Maßnahme das ist wahr nur die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben immer mehr
das Gefühl dass es zugeht wie auf dem
Basar was sie gerade zum Beispiel bei
der atomkraftveranstalten das ist doch
der Wahnsinn das sind parteipolitische
Ränkespiele das ist geschafft war es
geht nicht mehr um die Sache das ist das
Problem und der Kanzler duckt sich weg
der muss Therapiegespräche mit Herrn
Linder und Herrn Harbeck führen deswegen
sind die offensichtlich alle nicht da
das ist das Problem die Menschen draußen
erfahren was anderes als das was sie
hier darlegen seit Monaten explodieren
die Gaspreise die Bürger die bekommen
teilweise Rechnungen da denken Sie
zunächst diesen Druckfehler aber das ist
die Realität wir stehen vor der größten
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen Krise der
Nachkriegszeit meine Damen und Herren
das ist die Realität und der
Bundeskanzler beschwörtern you never
walk alone und Wumms und doppelwumms und
Bazooka die Realität immer weiter
steigende Preise und immer weiter
wachsende Unzufriedenheit im Land meine
Damen und Herren das was wir heute hier
diskutieren was sie diskutieren das
hätte im Juni diskutiert werden müssen
und vor allen Dingen entschieden werden
müssen ich habe hier drei Mal das Wort
schnell gehört ich dachte ich höre nicht
richtig das ist ihm nicht schnell
gewesen zu Beginn der Heizsaison im
Oktober hätte das vorliegen müssen und
die gaspreisbremse gelten müssen das
wäre richtig lieber Matthias Mörsch und
nicht erst im März was ist denn die re
alität das hier bis vor kurzem noch über
eine vermurkste gaspreisumlage geredet
worden ist ich erinnere mich noch an den
Wirtschaftsminister die muss weg
Opposition na was ist denn das für ein
agieren das ist das Problem sie haben
untereinander über Monate gestritten und
sich um die Menschen nur beiläufig
gekümmert und das ist verantwortungslos
sie sind eine zu spätkoalition meine
Damen und Herren das ist alles nach dem
Motto von Mark Twain nach dem Motto von
maxwain verschiebe nicht auf morgen was
du auch übermorgen kannst besorgen das
ist leider die Wahrheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt soll die
gaspreisbremse im März kommen
wie tritt für private also und Kraft
wenn die Saison vorbei ist das habe ich
doch richtig verstanden die Heizsaison
wesentlich vorbei ist wie absurd ist das
eigentlich und ich bin ja sehr froh
Matthias Mörsch das du sagst ja wir bin
auch sehr einverstanden wir müssen weit
über weitere Maßnahmen nachdenken da bin
ich sehr gespannt nämlich sehr gespannt
die mich dann gerne sehen deswegen lasse
ich das jetzt mal offen weil es denn
wenn das so stehen bleibt dann ist es
eine Zumutung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ich hoffe dass es wirklich
weitere Maßnahmen geht und dann liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt kommt der
Punkt die erste Stufe soll dann heißen
im Dezember wird die Gasrechnung für
alle übernommen ehrlich gesagt was heißt
denn das das heißt wenn eine Villa mit
Pool hat und acht Zimmern und richtig
mollig warmheizt der bekommt einen
fetten Rabatt vom Steuerzahler und die
Rentnerin die schon über Jahre gespart
hat und eine kleine Wohnung hat die
bekommt fast nichts das meine Damen und
Herren ist nicht gerecht wir ich kann
nur der Koalition sagen Millionäre und
übrigens auch Minister wir brauchen
keine Hilfe das ist eine absurde das ist
eine unsoziale Gießkanne was sie hier
vorschlagen sie sind nicht nur die zu
spät Koalition sie sind
auch Koalition meine Damen und Herren
ich will jetzt über die Strom und die
Spritpreise nicht weiter reden es droht
ihre
gaspreisbremse zu einer Luftnummer zu
werden und deswegen sehr einverstanden
sie muss dringend parlamentarisch
nachgearbeitet werden ja ausdrücklich
wir sind bereit da konstruktiv uns
einzubringen überhaupt keine Frage nur
der jetzige Vorschlag der ist wirklich
zutiefst sozial ungerecht ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen weil sie ja noch Vorschläge
rufen wir haben immer gesagt ein
grundton-kontingent was wir vorschlagen
8000 Kilowatt pro Haushalt 4.000
Kilowatt für jedes weitere Mitglied
Haushaltsmitglied preislich auf
Vorjahresniveau Deckeln damit könnten
die Familien planen und dann würden sie
auch deutlich entlastet werden meine
Damen und Herren aber
als zu spätkoalition und sozial
ungerecht Koalition betreiben sie halt
viel zu viel machtpolitische Spiele und
führen das Land damit nicht durch die
Krise nehmen sie endlich ihre
Verantwortung wahr und dabei müssen die
Menschen im Mittelpunkt stehen nicht die
Konzerne für die ist das eher vernünftig
für viele Menschen nicht herzlichen Dank
der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
Linksfraktion hier in dieser aktuellen
Stunde beantragt ja von den Fraktionen
der Ampelkoalition
für die SPD hören wir jetzt Nina Schere
die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja Herr Bartsch
wenn sie jetzt gerade aufgezählt haben
was sie alles an den Konzepten vermissen
die ja wohl bemerkt erst mal erste
Vorschläge sind das sind ja noch nicht
mal die Konzepte sind erste Vorschläge
und es ist jetzt der Bereich einer
weiteren Bereich in einer Reihe von sehr
sehr vielen Maßnahmen die wir schon
beschlossen haben das unterschlagen sie
dabei auch immer aber wenn sie dann
schon jetzt auf vermeintliches fehlen
abstellen ich habe jetzt bei ihnen nicht
herausgehört dass bei ihren
oberflächlich dargestellten Vorschlägen
jetzt nicht die willenbesitzer
profitiert hätten habe ich nicht
rausgehört also insofern es ist
natürlich genau bei Ihnen genau das
gleiche Problem wie bei uns allen wenn
wir Maßnahmen schnell machen wollen und
ich bin gar nicht absprechen dass sie
das wirklich auch beabsicht dass dann
man Schwierigkeiten bekommt ist wirklich
ganz zielgenau zu machen das ist einfach
das Hauptproblem was wir alle haben und
es ist einfach unredlich in Diskussionen
wie den hiesigen angesichts dieser so
dramatischen Situation immer wieder zu
unterstellen und zu suggerieren vor der
Öffentlichkeit zu suggerieren dass
dieses Problem nicht existieren würde
das ist unredlich und deswegen möchte
ich hier darauf nochmal Hinweisen
natürlich ist das Hauptproblem was wir
haben zur Ausgestaltung dieser
gaspreisbremse und auch weitere Hilfen
das war schon das ganze Jahr über die
Herausforderung dass wir einerseits
schnell die Menschen entlasten wollen
das haben wir auch getan einmal mit 30
Milliarden dann nochmal mit 60
Milliarden wir haben jetzt schon
beschlossen über 95 Milliarden jetzt
noch mal den Abwehrschirm mit 200
Milliarden für die nächsten Jahre
gestreckt und bei all den Maßnahmen ist
immer die gleiche Herausforderung wir
wollen es möglichst schnell hinbekommen
haben es bisher immer schnell geschafft
aber es muss zielgerichtet sein und
deswegen
haben wir natürlich vor dass auch ein
Steuerungsinstrument da ist das ist
versteuert werden soll damit eben nicht
die Reichen überproportional davon
profitieren sondern weniger davon
profitieren das ist natürlich an die
Bedürftigen zur allererst gehen sollen
und natürlich haben wir längst auf dem
Schirm das ist nicht nur
gasleitungsverbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher gibt es gibt auch
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher die
Tanks haben die an Öl hängen die mit
Holzpellets heizen natürlich gibt es die
aber wir müssen natürlich schauen dass
das Maß an Überforderung was wir haben
also dass die Menschen nicht überfordert
werden dass dieses Maß für uns
maßgeblich ist und es darf dann nicht zu
einer überproportionalen Überforderung
von anderen kommen sondern es muss
wirklich gerecht zu gehen alle müssen
gleichermaßen entlastet werden am
Maßstab ihrer Überforderung und genau
das wird die Ausgestaltung unserer
Arbeit sein die nächsten Wochen
zudem ist natürlich auch klar wenn man
eben dazu übergehen wird dann diese
Stufe auszugestalten dass ein bestimmter
Prozentsatz vom Jahresverbrauch dann in
einer gaspreisbremse sich wiederfindet
dass man da natürlich auch schaut ja das
ist erstmal schon ein großer
einsparanreiz wenn man mit Prozenten
eines Jahresverbrauchs Arbeit ist das
schon mal ein guter einsparanreiz aber
wir sind frei darin und es liegen die
Konzepte auf dem Tisch natürlich auch
weitergehende Anreize zu geben weil wir
wissen natürlich dass Anreize bzw
Einsparen von Gas nicht nur die
individuelle Rechnung runterdrückt
sondern jedes eingesparte Gas das jetzt
nicht dazu gekauft werden muss ist eine
Entlastung für alle weil einfach die
Preise so Herend hoch sind deswegen ist
das natürlich auch etwas was überprüft
wird
[Applaus]
und natürlich auch klare Obergrenzen es
kann nicht sein dass man sagt es werden
einfach angemessen am Verbrauch bis ins
Uferlose weil dann wäre natürlich
tatsächlich auch die Leute noch weiter
und die VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher
noch weiter
auch fördern die die einfach aufgrund
ihrer Bedarfssituation sehr viel Energie
bisher verbraucht haben und selbst bei
einem verminderten Anteil wäre das nicht
das richtige Signal deswegen braucht man
natürlich auch eine Obergrenze bei der
Unterstützung weil sonst würde auch dies
nicht zielgerichtet funktionieren
ich möchte ganz zum Schluss aber noch
mal auf zwei Punkte eingehen und zwar
eine ganz wichtige Aufgabenstellung wird
hierbei auch sein dass wir bei all den
Notfallmaßnahmen die wir jetzt erneut
auf den Weg bringen und die natürlich
flankieren dass wir eine fossile
energiepreiskrise haben dass dabei diese
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen nicht bewirken
dass wir die erneuerbaren Energien
zurückdrängen das darf nicht passieren
es muss nach wie vor ein stärkerer
Anreiz sein und eine Privilegierung für
erneuerbare Energien sein also wir
müssen gar sehr genau darauf achten dass
diese Privilegierung die wir auch
gesetzlich verankert haben dass die bei
all dem erhalten bleibt da darf keine
Überforderung in eine Richtung gehen die
uns von diesem Pfad abbringt weil dies
würde die Menschen auf mittel und
längerfristige Sicht massiv belasten
wenn wir Ihnen die Möglichkeit nehmen
schnellstmöglich auf erneuerbare
Energien umzusteigen vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege Dr Andreas Lenz ist jetzt
der nächste Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Kommission
Gas hat ihre Ergebnisse vorgelegt und
auch ich möchte mich ganz herzlich dafür
bedanken letzten Endes wurde ich hier ja
Arbeit gemacht die eigentlich die
Regierung leisten muss und dass die
Opposition hier nicht involviert war das
hatten wir zwar bedauert aber wir freuen
uns natürlich auch dass viele dass viele
unserer Vorschläge sich wiederfinden in
den entsprechenden Entwürfen der
gaskommission und des Tage nicht nur ich
das sagt auch die Frau Professor Grimm
heute im Handelsblatt und V Professor
Grimm bedauert auch dass diese
Kommission nicht früher eingesetzt wurde
und das bedauern wir auch wir haben
unsere Vorschläge seit Sommer
entsprechend vorliegen wir haben noch im
September einen Antrag zur Abstimmung
stellen wollen wo wir eine
Preisbremse für Gas gefordert hatten wo
wir einen
bürgerbasiskreis gefordert hatten und wo
wir außerdem Anreize zum Energiesparen
entsprechend auch setzen wollten eine
energiepauschale von 1000 Euro für
untere einkommensdrittel leider hat
damals die SPD die Grünen und die FDP
nicht zugestimmt und schon Anfang 22
Anfang diesen Jahres hat die CSU
übrigens eine
gaspreisdeckelung gefordert einen
Budgetansatz und die Ampel schaltet also
einmal wieder zu spät zu langsam sie
waren den ganzen Sommer mit einem
gasumlage-chaos beschäftigt sie können
die Entlastungen sie könnten die
Entlassungen jetzt schon einführen wenn
sie entsprechend nicht die Zahl vertutet
hätten und dann würde eben auch die
Entlastung nicht erst im April nächsten
Jahres gelten sondern schon jetzt und
wie gesagt das geht auf Ihr Konto
im April ist schließlich die Heizperiode
weitestgehend vorbei dann erst greifen
eine Vielzahl der entsprechenden
Entlastungen im April kann es für viele
Unternehmen aber bereits zu spät sein
das geht wie gesagt alles auf Ihr Konto
auf ihre Untätigkeit und jetzt mal
konkret zu den Vorschlägen der
Mittelstand soll zukünftig 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde Gas Zahlen genauso viel
wie die Verbraucher das ist natürlich
gut weil es eine Reduzierung ist aber
jetzt ist es so wenn ich die Vorschläge
entsprechend zu Ende lese dann könnte
das bedeuten dass der Bäcker zukünftig
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde Zeit das aber
der Großbäcker 7 Cent zahlt und es geht
doch nicht zusammen das benachteiligt
doch den Mittelstand des benachteiligt
doch gerade auf die kleinen gegenüber
die großen
und übrigens entlastet die SPD den
Gaspreis des
einkommensmillionärs das muss man ja
auch mal sich vergegenwärtigen wie das
entsprechend erklärt werden soll da bin
ich noch gespannt wohin gegen die
niedrigen Einkommen letzten Endes nur
mit einem gießkännchen entlastet werden
sollen das ist weder sozial noch gerecht
und da muss einen doch lieber Matthias
Mirsch dann muss ein doch das Herz eines
aufrechten Sozialdemokraten entsprechend
bluten und gleichzeitig und gleichzeitig
werden die Haushalte die unter hohen
Preisen die unter hohen Preisen für
Heizöl und Pellets leiden nicht
entlastet die passendes zusammen das
passt überhaupt nicht zusammen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
die die Reduzierung des Gaspreises pro
Kilowattstunde um einen Cent kostet pro
Jahr acht bis zehn Milliarden Euro das
ist enorm und das ist dauerhaft auch
nicht zu leisten umso wichtiger ist es
dass jetzt alle Ressourcen auf der
Angebotsseite entsprechend auch wirklich
genutzt werden nutzbar gemacht werden
wir brauchen der
satzbeschaffungsmaßnahmen da wird viel
gesprochen aber wenig geliefert im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und übrigens
auch was den Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke betrifft brauchen wir
jetzt wirkliche Planungssicherheit
brauchen auch die Betreiber
entsprechende Planungssicherheit und da
liefern sich Lindner und Haarwerk einen
einen Schaukampf auf offener Bühne das
ist nicht verantwortungsvoll meine Damen
und Herren und letzten Endes ist es doch
so je höher das Angebot ist je höher das
Angebot ist desto niedriger ist der
Preis und das ist auch die günstigste
Form und entsprechend die Preise auch zu
senken
ja wir brauchen schnell Ergebnisse und
die Vorschläge sind noch längst nicht
umgesetzt es geht jetzt wirklich schnell
zu tun auch zielgenau zu machen
unbürokratisch zu machen und wir hoffen
sehr dass es kein wir hoffen sehr dass
es kein nächstes hier Auskunft wie bei
der gasumlage entsprechend gibt damit
wäre niemanden geholfen also fordern wir
fordern sie auf handeln sie wirklich
schnell und handeln Sie zielgerichtet
sonst ist es für viele in diesem Land zu
spät herzlichen Dank
ja die Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm
eine der Vorsitzenden der
Expertenkommission die hätte sich
tatsächlich etwas mehr Zeit gewünscht
für die Vorschläge bis 6:30 Uhr Montag
früh hatte die Expertenkommission ja
sozusagen eine Klausur an diesem
Wochenende um dann diese Vorschläge um
diesen Zwischenbericht vorzulegen Dieter
janitschek jetzt für die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
der Abwehrschirm den die Menschen in der
Ukraine bräuchten ist einer vor den
schrecklichen Angriffskrieg der
russischen Armee mit Bomben wir
diskutieren heute über den Abwehrschirm
für unsere Volkswirtschaft für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für kleine
mittelständische Unternehmen das ist
wichtig aber es ist auch wichtig dass in
den Kontext zu stellen wir sind deswegen
heute hier weil Russland weil Putin in
der Ukraine diesen schrecklichen Krieg
führt
ich möchte mich bedanken bei den
Mitgliedern der unabhängigen Kommission
Erdgas und Wärme ich finde sie haben
kluge Vorschläge geliefert natürlich
sind wir jetzt gefordert im Verfahren
diese zu bewerten und auch noch zu
prüfen der mir stark zu Recht über die
sozialen Auswirkungen für den Einzelnen
aber erst einmal grundsätzlich ist eine
Botschaft ganz wichtig wir haben als
Bundesregierung als Koalition vorgesorgt
wir kommen gut durch den Winter vor
allem wenn wir auch kraftvoll weiter
daran arbeiten Energie einzusparen auf
der anderen Seite Angebot auszuweiten
und die Maßnahmen die wir jetzt bei der
Entlastung machen auch kräftig zu
vollziehen das heißt wir haben eine
klare Kursreaktion hier geschaffen und
das ist entscheidend
wenn man sich die Vorschläge jetzt
anschaut ist ja der Einspareffekt
vorgesehen die Industrie soll nach
Vorschlägen von Frau Grimm und anderen
Professor Grimm
jetzt 70 Prozent ihres Verbrauchs aufs
Verbrauchs der 21 gedeckelt bekommen und
dafür einen Beschaffungspreis von 7 Cent
und Liebe Andreas Lenz das eine ist der
Beschaffungspreis 7 Cent das andere ist
der garantierte Verbrauchspreis da
kommen nämlich noch Netzentgelt andere
Sachen drauf ich glaube das wissen sie
ziemlich genau deswegen ist die
Spreizung ist zwischen dem
Industriepreis und dem Mittelstandspreis
nicht so hoch wie Sie tun kann im
Einzelfall sogar gleich sein also das
ist einfach eine Frage wo man ansetzt
diese 70 Prozent heißen aber auch dass
weiter eingespart werden mussten so ist
es auch bei den Verbrauchern wir können
den Menschen ja nicht sagen und deswegen
halte ich es auch für richtig dass wir
nicht jetzt rückwirkend Maßnahmen
beschlossen aber bei der Entlastung oder
dass wir sagen es gibt jetzt eine
Einmalzahlung damit bitte
investiert die wenn ihr müsst auch in
eure Ausgaben die ihr habt auf der
Gasseite auf der stromseite aber bitte
spart auch einen diesen Winter so weit
ihr das könnt und das ist eine ganz
wesentliche Botschaft denn Lukas Köhler
hat das völlig zurecht gesagt das
schlimmste Szenario was wir haben können
ist dass wir durch eine erhöhten
Verbrauch doch noch in eine gasmangel
Lage kommen dann haben wir wirklich mit
Zitronen gehandelt und dann sind wir in
einer veritablen Wirtschaftskrise die
wir nicht mehr aufhalten können
jetzt ist ja die Frage auch was wir
lernen können aus dem Prozessen eins
können wir lernen als wir die Regierung
übernommen haben fehlten uns viele Daten
zum Beispiel bei den Gas Verbräuchen der
Wenzel weiß das genau uns fehlen heute
noch die Daten wie wir beispielsweise
Einmalzahlungen übertragen können also
dieses Thematik von
Entlastungsmöglichkeiten Christian
Lindner weiß das auch daran wird
gearbeitet dass das in der Zukunft
besser ist damit man Instrumente zur
Verfügung hat und zu reagieren die wir
heute nicht haben deswegen sind
bestimmte Maßnahmen die wir heute
tätigen eben auch davon abhängig wie wir
sie realisieren können auch das gehört
zu Wahrheit und deswegen ist dieser
Punkt der Einmalzahlung im Dezember
jetzt ein richtiger und wichtiger weil
er unbürokratisch ist den Menschen etwas
in die Hand gibt dass sie durch den
Winter kommen aber das klare Signal dann
auch dass am Ende des Winters ein
garantierter Preis auch Gas und Strom
und ich denke bei Strom werden wir
analog Handeln zur Verfügung steht das
schafft Planungssicherheit für die
Industrie für die Wirtschaft für die
Kunden für die Verbraucher und das ist
dass wir in dem Gesamtkontext gehandelt
haben mit den 95 Milliarden Euro die wir
jetzt schon Entlastung handeln das ist
eine Strategie und die lässt sich sehen
und die ist richtig dieser ökonomisch
sinnvoll und es ist übrigens auch
sinnvoll zu sagen dass wir jetzt die
Inflation dadurch bekämpfen denn wenn
wir die Preise senken wird die Inflation
auch runtergehen sein erster Schritt sie
wird noch nicht unter 5% kommen nächstes
Jahr aber wenigstens mal auf sieben auch
das ist ein Schritt den wir tun also das
ist alles durchdacht und das sind eine
gute Strategie die die Koalition hier
vorlegt
jetzt ist die Frage immer natürlich kann
man es allen Recht machen nein ist
ehrlich man kann es nicht allen recht
machen das ist auch die Aussage der
Kommission sie können keine
einzelfallgerechte Maßnahme in einem
Vorschlag unterbringen wenn jemand zum
Beispiel beim Thema Heizöl ein
Heizöltank voll gemacht hat im letzten
Winter zu den alten kosten dann hat er
den vielleicht jetzt noch für den
nächsten Winter solche Kessel gibt es ja
dann hat er die alten Preise wenn er
jetzt jemand gekauft hat für 150 Euro
hat er höhere Kosten wie soll ich darauf
als Staat reagieren durch Entlastung für
die Allgemeinheit aber ich kann das
nicht fallbezogen entscheiden und
deswegen das Signal der Debatte ist
heute das ist ein guter Vorschlag den
schauen wir uns jetzt an wir werden da
zügig entscheiden wir werden das
sozialen Kriterien auch entlasten aber
nochmal wir kommen durch den Winter gut
das ist schon mal die Signal was wir
durch die Arbeit der Bundesregierung den
letzten Monate gegeben haben Gasspeicher
voll in den Terminals kommen Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien aber entscheidend
bleibt sparen wir gemeinsam Energie ein
das ist entscheidend um gut durch den
Winter zu kommen und entscheidend auch
für die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen Industrie vielen Dank ja
ab der ja immer gesagt hat ja Energie
einsparen
bleibt natürlich auch ein Gebot dieses
Winters
Michael Kruse jetzt für die FDP der
nächste hier am Rednerpult
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind ja nun
mal im Bereich der Energie in eine große
Abhängigkeit geraten und deswegen ist es
unser Ziel als Regierung und als
regierungstragende Fraktion aus dieser
Abhängigkeit schnellstmöglich
rauszukommen und wieder in der
Energieunabhängigkeit zu kommen und mit
Abhängigkeit und Entzug der Ressource
bei der hier die Abhängigkeit besonders
groß ist und das ist das Gas entstehen
nicht nur jede Menge gesetzgeberische
Aktivitäten sondern es steht bei
entsteht bei einem großen Teil der
Wirtschaft und der Bevölkerung große
Sorge und hier kommt Politik ins Spiel
wir haben die Möglichkeiten Sorgen zu
vergrößern oder wir haben die
Möglichkeiten Sorgen ernst zu nehmen und
mit Lösungen daran zu arbeiten dass wir
sie in den Griff bekommen und dass wir
die Probleme die sie sorgen begründen
lösen wenn Sie hier am Rand sitzen dann
waren sie auch heute in der Debatte
wieder damit beschäftigt auf sorgen
drauf zu satteln sie zu vergrößern sie
herbeizureden viel Zeit darauf zu
verwenden zu beschreiben warum man sich
diese Sorgen machen muss und warum die
Regierung mich handelt oder Sie setzen
hier eher in der Mitte des Hauses und
wenn sie in der Mitte des Hauses sitzen
dann sind sie so wie wir damit
beschäftigt Lösungen zu erarbeiten um
den Menschen in diesem Land die Sorgen
zu nehmen das ist unsere Aufgabe als
verantwortungsvolle Politikerinnen und
Politiker
und genau solche Lösungen genau solche
Lösungen hat die Kommission in ziemlich
hoher Geschwindigkeit erarbeitet und
dafür gebührt ihr Dank und Respekt und
das ist etwas was wir anerkennen
inhaltlich haben wir ja schon einiges
gehört heute wir haben wichtige Ziele
die es zu erreichen gilt mit diesem
maßnahmen-set wir müssen die
spar-anreize hochhalten wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass unsere konkrete Gesetzgebung
fair ausgestaltet ist wir wollen eine
schnelle Umsetzung und wir wollen eine
unbürokratische Umsetzung die Messlatte
liegt hoch und ich kann Ihnen
versprechen wir werden über diese Latte
springen
und mit dem klaren Zielen die wir hier
formulieren mit den klaren Zielen die
wir hier formulieren nehmen wir den
Menschen ihre Sorgen nämlich ist die
größte Sorge das ist so schlimm bleiben
könnte wie es aktuell ist etwa dass die
Gaspreise so hoch bleiben könnten wie
sie in diesem Sommer gewesen sind und
deswegen ergreifen wir konkrete
Maßnahmen um aus der Abhängigkeit
rauszukommen und um damit auch die
Sorgen der Menschen in diesem Land in
den Griff zu kriegen ich nenne nun mal
die Themen lng-speicher wir haben sie
gefüllt das war unser erstes Gesetz im
März dieses Jahres heute sind wir über
94 Prozent wer hätte das ernsthaft
gedacht der Ausbau der lng-terminals in
einer Rekordgeschwindigkeit
Wilhelmshaven 28 Kilometer Leitung sind
schon unterwegs eine einsparkampagne wie
sie dieses Land nicht erlebt hat und
natürlich in den aktuellen Tagen mit den
Sorgen um das was wir als Anschläge im
Moment sehen auch der Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur dieses alles
als Basis für die Versorgung der
Menschen in diesem Land und wenn man das
jetzt mal alles zusammen nimmt dann kann
man bestimmte Wirkprinzipien erkennen
die wir hier zur Anwendung bringen das
erste ist wir ein klares Ziel aus der
Energieabhängigkeit rauskommen das
zweite ist ein großes Engagement und da
verstehe ich auch die Kritik der
Opposition ehrlich gesagt nicht denn
natürlich ist es gut die Versorger die
Ökonomen die Wissenschaftler alle mit am
Tisch zu haben um gemeinsam etwas zu
erarbeiten um gemeinsam das beste
Konzept zu erarbeiten und da verstehe
ich dann wirklich nicht was da
eigentlich die Kritik sein sollte
andersrum wenn wir uns das alles im
stillen Kämmerlein ausgedacht hätten
dann hätten sie doch einen Grund zur
Kritik wir haben hier mit dem größten
möglichen auch gesellschaftlichen
Engagement dafür gesorgt dass hier gute
Konzepte erarbeitet werden Klarheit
Engagement Geschwindigkeit und am Ende
produzieren diese drei Werte
Verlässlichkeit meine lieben Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und das wird auch schon
deutlich an den Märkten wir haben in
diesem Sommer Höchstpreise am Spotmarkt
für Gas von 320 Euro gesehen aktuell
schwanken wir um 100 Euro wir sind von
320 auf 100 Euro gefallen das ist das
Ergebnis einer Politik die in diesem
Land sichtbar wird und das ist immer
noch zu viel das möchte ich Ihnen sagen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
immer noch zu viel aber es ist nicht
mehr ruinös für unsere ganze
Volkswirtschaft und deswegen werden wir
diesen Weg auch weitergehen nämlich mit
verantwortungsvollen Maßnahmen den
Menschen in diesem Land ihre Sorgen zu
nehmen und wo Sorge gibt da gibt es auch
immer Hoffnung und ich frage mich bei
jedem einzelnen Redner und bei jeder
einzelnen Rednerin was tragen sie
eigentlich dazu bei den Menschen in
diesem Land in dieser schwierigen
Situation Hoffnung zu machen mit
entschlossenem Handeln mit beherztem
eingreifen und mit guten
gesetzgeberischen Maßnahmen werden wir
diese Hoffnung erarbeiten und deswegen
freue ich mich auf den weiteren
gesetzgeberischen Prozess zur
gaspreisbremse herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
Kruse war dass der energiepolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion hier in der
Aktuellen Stunde zur gaspreiskommission
und ihren Vorschlägen als nächstes
spricht Julia Klöckner für die
Unionsfraktion sie ist die
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kollege
Kruse sie sprachen davon von Hoffnung
machen also eines kann ich Ihnen sagen
was den Bürgern keine Hoffnung gemacht
hat war ihr gerade rund um die Gas
Umlage und wenn das Hoffnung machen soll
was Sie heute hier ich nenne es jetzt
mal eher einen Stuhlkreis der
Ampelkoalition zu den Ergebnissen dieser
Kommission es ist ja schon sehr
bezeichnend es ist ja Sie müssen auch
mal ertragen dass man sie kritisiert es
ist sehr sehr bezeichnend wie sie heute
hier reingehen dass sie von den
lng-speichern Sprachen die gefüllt sind
ich gehe davon aus dass das ein Fehler
war und nicht ihr Erkenntnisgewinn ist
sie haben von lng-speicher gesprochen um
die geht es hier nicht dann lassen wir
das dann stellen wir das einfach mal
klar aber es gehört ja auch dazu dass
wir den Sorgen der Menschen wirklich
auch Ernsthaftigkeit Entgegenkommen
lassen und der Bundeskanzler kommt
vielleicht so gerne zu uns ins Parlament
wie wir festgestellt haben wenn ich
jetzt wandern wäre Zeit für eine
Regierungserklärung damit er Kanzler
über die Lage in diesem Land einmal
spricht und auch einmal erklärt denn
dass die Kollegin von den Grünen vorhin